Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaosradio 222, das dieses Mal wieder in Berlin stattfindet. Live in der Marienstraße, da wird gerade was aufgezeigt. Ja, bitte. Begeisterung. Das eine war das Publikum und das andere waren seltsame Dinge, die im Hintergrund passieren. Wir testen heute auch Remote Gäste. Das haben wir hier glaube ich noch nie gemacht in der Marienstraße 11, in der ihr noch gerne vorbeikommen könnt. Deswegen klingt es gleich zwischendurch ein bisschen komisch. Wir geben uns aber Mühe. Apropos Marienstraße 11, das Thema der heutigen Sendung sind Orte, und zwar sogenannte Hackerspaces oder Hackerspaces oder Hackspaces. All das werden wir heute in der Sendung klären. Und es sind sehr viele Gäste, also nicht nur das klatschende und sehr begeisterte Publikum, vielen Dank dafür schon mal, sondern auch Herr Johl. Hallo und guten Abend. Ach nee, das ist der da, entschuldigung.
Hallo.
Der Pylon. Die Cat. Und der Gizmo.
Schönen guten Abend.
Und ihr seid alle von verschiedenen, wie heißt das denn jetzt eigentlich? Hackerspaces, Hackspaces, Hackspaces. Man sagt ja auch gerne Hacker eigentlich, also so im CTC-Umfeld hab ich zumindest das Gefühl. Wie heißt das denn jetzt richtig? Wo reden wir denn heute? Hat jemand mal eine Wortmeldung? Hackspaaas. Hackspaces, okay. Das sind, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, sozusagen Orte, in denen sich Hacker treffen. Und die gibt es dann aber in so vielen verschiedenen und Hackerinnen. Und das ist aber sozusagen schon die einzige Gemeinsamkeit, die man sagen kann, weil dann gibt es das in ganz vielen Geschmacksrichtungen. Dann gibt es irgendwie Fab Labs und Makerspaces und weiss ja gar alles. Und wir wollen das heute mal alles genau besprechen, damit man nicht nur weiß, dass es sowas überhaupt gibt, sondern möglicherweise sogar, wie man das machen kann. Jetzt würde ich von euch gerne erst mal, wir kommen noch ganz ausführlich drauf, aber erst mal ganz kurz wissen, welchen Hackspace ihr heute ertretet.
Oh, ganz viele. Ja, die Historie ist lang. Ich hab mehrere mit aufgebaut. Aktuell bin ich hier in CCCB unterwegs, oder auch in der Afra, oder wahrscheinlich gemäß demnächst auch ein bisschen mehr in dem neuen Hackerspace in Friedrichshain.
So, so.
In Berlin bin ich am häufigsten in der C-Base, aber ich hab auch schon ein bisschen Historie hinter mir und hab auch schon drei Hackerspaces mit aufgebaut.
Das hört sich jetzt so an, wenn man einmal in ein Hackerspace geht, dann führt das zwangsweise dazu, dass man anfängt selber. Ist das ansteckend?
Das ist ansteckend, ja.
Ich bin hier für die Heart of Code. Das ist ein Hackspace für Frauen, den wir gerade in Berlin gründen.
Und du warst vorher auch schon andern, oder?
Das ist mein erster. Ich bin manchmal hier am CCCB, aber nicht regelmäßig.
Ich mach als Betreuer hier im Welling in Berlin auch den Hackerspace-Raumfahrtagentur. Historisch hab ich noch mit ein paar anderen was zu tun. An der Stelle auch das LobRoy 23. Das sind die Kollegen aus dem Süden, aus Würzburg. Ich bin auch mit den beiden Herrn Pülhorn und Joel seit Längerem mit dem Thema verwandelt. Lange Jahre.
Meine Güte. Was ist denn jetzt eigentlich in den Hackspace? Wenn man hier in die Marienstraße 11 reinkommt, was ihr gerne tun könnt, weil die Sendung ist live und vor Ort, ihr könnt sie sowohl im Video auf streaming.media.ccc.de gucken, was eigentlich egal ist, ist die Ansage. Weil wenn ihr es hört, dann wisst ihr, wo das ist. Aber fürs nächste Mal vielleicht, falls ihr es als Podcast hört. Da kommt man rein, da gibt es einen großen Raum, der hat so Fabrikhallen-Flair, es hängt an den Diskokugeln an der Decke, viele seltsame Plakate an der Wand, es gibt eine Treppe nach unten, es hängt ein großes Schild, das man eigentlich auf einem Bahnhof vermuten würde an der Wand. Manchmal ist es sogar auch erleuchtet. Und es gibt einen Tisch, auf dem viele Kabel liegen und ein paar Sofas und Stühle und Technik in der Ecke, die ermöglicht, dass ihr das hier hört. Aber was ist eigentlich ein Hackspace? Wofür ist es da? Was macht man da? Was soll das Ganze überhaupt? Ich vermute, wie bei vielen Hackerthemen, ist es so, vier Leute, fünf Erklärungen. Gizmo, was ist ein Hackspace für dich? Eigentlich. Also was ist die Essenz davon?
Einen Punkt zu haben, in dem sich Leute, die an Technik und der Basilei interessiert sind, zu treffen. Eine Möglichkeit zu haben, Austausch zu betreiben dort. Sowohl am Gerät, gerade aus der klassischen Sache, hier im CCCB mit Computern und Co. aber wenn es dann ein bisschen weiter in Richtung Hacker- und Makerspace geht, dann geht es da auch um das Teilen von Maschinen und Werkzeug, was ja jetzt nicht so sinnvoll ist, wenn jeder Einzelne da zu Hause was basteln muss, sondern dass man halt die Möglichkeit hat, den Zugang auch zu teureren Anlagen gemeinsam überhaupt zu finanzieren erstmal, dass so ein Gerät überhaupt da ist und benutzbar ist. Und natürlich dann auch entsprechend mehrere Leute das Ganze verwenden können.
Also dass da Werkzeug vorhanden ist oder Arbeitsmöglichkeiten, das ist schon auch gehört zur Quintessenz von Hackspace.
Ja, würde ich mich jetzt mal anschließen. Das ist irgendwie ein Ort, an dem man sich mit Technik auseinandersetzen kann und auch gemeinsam an Ideen und Projekten arbeiten kann und wo auch Wissenstransfer stattfindet, also dass man sich austauschen kann und voneinander lernen und Spaß haben.
Ich hab noch eine ganz hochtrabende, synthologische Erklärung. Ja, es gibt diesen Begriff des Third Places, also der Ort, der weder Arbeit slash Schule oder Uni noch das Zuhause ist. Das ist irgendwie so in der Stadtplanung ein Begriff. Das kann irgendwie ein Freizeitzentrum sein, das kann irgendwie die Eckkneipe sein, aber das kann halt auch ein Hackerspace sein für die Leute, die halt irgendwie eher digital sind und deren Freunde halt im Computer leben. Die treffen sich in ihrem Third Place halt in so einem Hackerspace. Und in einem von den Hackerspaces, den wir in Bonn gegründet haben, dem Netzladen, da muss man sich ja immer dann, wenn man in Deutschland einen Verein gründet, dann versucht man das dann auch irgendwie in schönen deutschen Worten zusammenzufassen. Da hat man es als Untertitel gegeben, Raum für selbstverwaltete Technik, Politik und Kultur.
Okay, also da stecken ja schon irgendwie zwei Anschlussfragen wieder drin. Das eine ist, muss man einen Verein gründen, um mal Hackspace zu haben, kommen wir später noch zu. Aber die andere möchte ich gleichstellen, und das ist, weil du jetzt gesagt hast, sowas wie eine Gaststätte kann das auch sein, ist ein Hackspace immer ein öffentlicher Ort? Also wo jeder rein kann?
Ist schwierig, da gibt es auch ganz unterschiedliche Modelle. Muss man auch nicht irgendwie vorschreiben oder so. Die meisten sind halt so semiöffentlich. Also es gibt eine Möglichkeit irgendwie reinzukommen. Also es ist jetzt nicht völlig abgeschlossen, aber oft ist das dann halt auch irgendwie mit einer Mitgliedschaft verbunden. Oder die Leute möchten dann halt irgendwie sagen, ja wir haben halt einmal im Monat oder einmal in der Woche eine öffentliche Veranstaltung. Es gibt aber auch Hackerspaces, Hackspaces, die sind völlig offen. Da kann jeder jederzeit reinkommen.
Aber sozusagen, wenn man als interessierter Neuanfänger davon hört, es ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist hoch, dass man da reinkommen kann. Auch als sozusagen jemand Fremdes, aber man kann nicht davon ausgehen, dass die Tür jederzeit offen ist.
Ganz genau. Und Türen und Hackerspaces ist auch so ein Thema, was wir vielleicht noch sprechen sollten.
Wer hat eigentlich einen Schlüssel? Genau darüber sprechen wir noch. Pülon, was ist ein Hackspace?
Für mich ist es so das erweiterte Wohnzimmer. Vor allen Dingen aus Seiten, wo ich halt kleine Wohnungen hatte, war es ganz gut halt einen Ort zu haben, wo ich mich mit Freunden treffen konnte, gleichgesinnten treffen konnte und wo ich auch mit anderen zusammen dann halt zum Beispiel Vorträge machen kann oder Workshops allen bieten kann. Also wo Platz einfach da ist, der halt zu Hause nicht da ist, aber in einem mehr oder weniger öffentlichen Raum, wie wir gerade schon gehört haben, was anzubieten kann, was ja mehr Menschen interessiert, die dann halt auch gemeinsam etwas arbeiten können.
Wenn man sich jetzt die Liste an Hackspaces anguckt, ihr habt jetzt alle schon irgendwie mehrfach Namen genannt und da sind die größten ja alle in Berlin.
Würde ich so nicht sagen.
Nein, nein, die größten, die ihr gesagt habt, sozusagen der größte Teil von dem, was ihr jetzt gerade alle erzählt habt, das spielt sich irgendwie hier in Berlin ab. Und das heißt, in Deutschland gibt es auch noch mehr, wenn man sich hier beschäftigt. Ist das schon immer so? Oder ist das sozusagen eine Entwicklung der letzten Jahre? So was wie Bubble Tea.
Es hält länger als Bubble Tea.
Das ist schon mal gut. Aber wie alt ist diese Idee? Also ich meine, klar irgendwie schon im Mittelalter haben sich die Alchemisten vielleicht in gemeinsamen Brauhöhlen getroffen. Und vielleicht war das schon ein Hackspace. Aber dieses so, Leute, korrigieren wir nicht, dass ich das falsch sage, aber Leute, die selbe Interesse haben und irgendwas mit Technik zu tun haben und so eine Art Wohnzimmer-slash-Werkstatt einrichten, das gibt es schon seit den 50ern, 60ern, 70ern, 80ern? Also wie alt ist das?
Meine Hackspaces haben ja meistens auch etwas mit Technik zu tun. Vor allem elektronischer Technik. Elektronik ist auch noch nicht so alt. Also wie du schon sagtest, 50er, 60er Jahre halt. Und es geht so ein bisschen auf diesen alten Hacker Club oder den, was war das? Der Railroad Club oder sowas? Am MIT halt zurück in Boston. Dass sie sich dort getroffen haben und dann halt irgendwie an ihren Modelleisenbahnen erst rumgespielt haben, was dann später aber auch so ein Treffpunkt wurde für die ersten Computerfreaks so gesehen. Das hat sich dann ein bisschen weiterentwickelt oder vielleicht ein bisschen auch eingeschlafen in den USA. Und das hat sich dann hier so in Deutschland erst wieder so entwickelt. Ja, mit dem CCC quasi. Dass dann der CCC selbst halt auch eigene Räume aufgemacht hatte, auch andere Ableger gegründet hatte. Und so vor allen Dingen in den 90er Jahren so ab der Zeit, wo es dann auf einmal dieses Internet gab, sich dann auch immer mehr Leute auch lokal getroffen haben, um sich austauschen zu können.
Und was gehört für einen Hackspace alles dazu? Also was muss da drin sein? Gibt es da eine Liste, was man sagen kann oder?
Für Hackspace ist eher weniger. Also das ist eher so ein offener Raum. Aber du hast vorhin den Begriff FabLab noch angesprochen. Und da gibt es tatsächlich so eine Liste, was so ein FabLab irgendwie alles haben sollte.
Was ist denn überhaupt ein FabLab?
Fabrication Laboratory heißt das eigentlich so komplett ausgesprochen. Also ein Raum, wo bestimmte Technik vorhanden ist, wo bestimmte Werkzeuge vorhanden sein sollten. Es gibt auch irgendwie eine Scharta dazu, was alles da sein sollte, damit man weiß, ich kann irgendwo auf der Welt in ein FabLab reingehen und kann mein Projekt dort weiterentwickeln oder fertigstellen. Weil ich weiß, die haben bestimmte Sachen dort. Seien es Werkzeuge, seien es vielleicht auch nur Bauteile, die ich brauche, um ein Elektronikrum zu basteln. Und das ist einfach vorhanden.
Aber gibt es da so ein Gütesiegel?
Ja, das Standardisierungsgremium, natürlich nichts Großes. Aber es ist eine Bemühung, da so ein bisschen das Protokoll zusammenzuhalten, was für Anlagen, was für Maschinen da sind. Das so ein bisschen zu definieren, was dazugehört aus dem Bereich Elektrotechnik. Laser-Cut, das ist ja oft dabei. 3D-Druck, das moderne Thema.
Lass uns mal überhalten, nicht so schnell. Das würde ich jetzt natürlich gerne genau wissen. Weil Maschinen hört sich ja wirklich an so eine Werkzeughalle.
Dort ist der Düsen-Triebwerkstestplatz. Wenn die Finanzierung stimmt, umso besser hat das seine Grenzen, was die Investition betrifft. Und hier ist schon ein Fokus darauf, dass das Anlagen und Größen sind, die handhabbar sind, sag ich mal. Also eben nicht der Triebwerksteststand.
Aber dein Lasercutter, was ist dein Lasercutter? Ich muss echt doof fragen.
Eine Möglichkeit, mit einem Laserstrahl XY auszuschneiden aus einer Vorlage, einer 2D-Sheet-Material, Plastik oder Papier. Je nachdem kann man ein zweidimensionales ausschneiden. Wie ein Stiftplotter, der malt nur keine Linie, sondern der brennt halt das Material durch.
Ein Lasercutter, ein 3D-Drucker?
Die kennt man ja gerade überall. Sehr beliebt, sehr bunt, viel Plastik, Brennter. Die Elektrotechnik, E-Technik, klassisch, Lötkolben, Oszilloskop.
FabLab ist ein Ort, wo sich da auch Leute treffen und wo es keinen TÜV-Siegel gibt, aber wo man damit rechnen kann, da gibt es einen bestimmten Satz von Werkzeugen. Wo man Sachen herstellen kann.
Wir haben in Köln einen FabLab mitbegleitet und das hieß dann Dingfabrik. Das trifft das eigentlich ganz gut.
Ich freu mich aber, wenn der FabLab ein Ort ist, wo man Dinge herstellen kann, was ist dann ein Makerspace?
Das ist ein FabLab mit einem gewissen Style oder so.
Hackerspace war doch öfters mal gerade im amerikanischen Raum die Diskussion, dass man wegen der Öffentlichkeitswirkungen vielleicht nicht diesen Begriff Hacker an der Stelle benutzt. Da ist sehr viel aus der Geschichte raus geworden, dass das Wording Richtung Makerspace eben ging. So viel weiter weg ist man gar nicht, außer dass man da so ein bisschen PC versucht.
Das halte ich auch für ein bisschen feige.
Ihr zählt hier in der Liste von Dingen, wie man Orte nennen kann, an denen sich Leute treffen und auch mit Sachen arbeiten, steht auch Co-Working Space. Jetzt hast du aber vorhin gesagt, das ist ja eigentlich ein dritter Ort, wo gerade nicht gearbeitet. Wie passt das jetzt zusammen?
Ach, die Übergänge sind so fließend. Es gibt ein Verzeichnis von Hackerspaces, das heißt auch hackerspaces.org. Da gibt es einen Wiki drauf und da sind alle möglichen aufgezeichnet. Und weil es halt einfach total schwierig ist, da Grenzen zu ziehen, ist da halt maximale Inklusion angesagt bei dieser Auflistung. Und da sind auch Leute hingekommen und haben gesagt, hey, wir machen eine Fahrradwerkstatt. Dürfen wir auch in euer Verzeichnis von Hackerspaces? Und dann ist da halt auch eine Fahrradwerkstatt drin. Weil irgendwie kann man auch argumentieren, dass das auch eine Art von Hackerspace ist. Es gibt Hackerspaces, die so ein bisschen in Richtung Co-Working-Space gehen. Ich würde da auch eher sagen, ein Co-Working-Space ist nicht das Gleiche wie ein Hackerspace. Aber es gibt viele Hackerspaces, wo dann halt Projekte entstehen, Leute sich zusammenfinden und sagen, hier, da können wir auch irgendwie ein Geschäft draus machen. Und warum sollen die dann zum Arbeiten auch nicht im Hackerspace sein? Also es wäre schwieriger, da jetzt genaue Grenzen zu ziehen, als das mal einfach sagt, ja.
Aber eine Grenze ist ja das liebe Geld. Ein Co-Working-Space ist ja, also für mich zumindest, bis jetzt sehr klar definiert dadurch gewesen, wenn ich da hin will und dort einen Platz haben will, dann zahle ich halt und zwar irgendwie auch tageweise oder sowas. Jetzt habe ich ein Hackerspace eher so verstanden, als es ist halt so ein semiöffentlicher Ort, wo ich erst mal hinkommen kann.
Es gibt ja auch Co-Working-Spaces, die durchaus im künstlerischen Bereich angesiedelt sind. Die haben dann halt auch entsprechende Werkstätten mit dabei. Und da findet man dann sehr viel die Leute, die halt gleich mit Textil was machen, vielleicht auch irgendwie mit ihren Gipsfiguren rummatschen oder so was in der Richtung, die dann tatsächlich, wie ich jetzt gerade schon sagte, in den Bereich reingehen, ja auch irgendwie Geld daraus hinterzumachen und dafür halt einen Platz zu bieten.
Das beantwortet meine Frage aber nicht wirklich.
Ich wollte es nur ergänzen halt gerade.
Okay, na also ein klassischer Hackerspace in Deutschland ist eigentlich ziemlich abgegrenzt vom Co-Working-Space. Aber die Welt ist rund, die Welt ist bunt. Es gibt alle möglichen Modelle. Sowas wie einen eingetragenen Verein, das haben wir hier halt in Deutschland. Und da sind wir total schnell dabei. Und alle sind wir Mitglieder in mehreren Vereinen und so weiter. Und das ist auch relativ einfach zu machen. Das ist nicht überall auf der Welt so. Also einer der Hackerspaces, die mir so am Herzen liegen, das ist NYC Resistor, New York City Resistor in Brooklyn, in New York. Und die zum Beispiel haben sich gleich von Anfang an entschieden, dass sie das als Äquivalent zu einer GmbH formieren. Also die haben halt nicht... Also entweder treibt man einen Riesenaufwand, um diese steuerbegünstigte Non-Profit-Sonstpass-Organisation zu machen. Oder es ist halt sehr, sehr einfach, so was GmbH-mäßiges aufzuziehen. Und dann ist das halt auf dem Papier ein kommerzielles Unternehmen. Aber es unterscheidet sich dann nicht wirklich vom Hackerspace, wie wir ihn hier in Europa finden.
Dann, ähm, man verlässt immer so schnell die Ebene des romantisch-naiven Hippiesken. Und das war so, Hackerspace hört ja so ein bisschen an, also semi-offen, da treffen sich Leute, arbeiten zusammen und so. Und dann zack, muss ja irgendjemand organisieren. GmbH-Gründen. Wie läuft denn sowas ab, so eine Hackerspace-Gründung? Könnt ihr da vielleicht mal alle Beispiele dazu sagen? Also GmbH kommt jetzt aus der Raumfahrtagentur was, ne? Das ist ja ein eher geschlossener Space, oder?
Also wir haben jetzt keine öffentlichen Termine, wie jetzt hier Club Discordia oder den offenen Donnerstag oder solche Sachen. Das nicht, ist schon erstmal die geschlossene Werkstatt von den Leuten, die dort eingebucht sind. Wer in der Raumfahrtagentur mit dabei ist, ist Kosmonaut. Und das ist schon auch an den Mitgliedsbeitrag gebunden. Natürlich sind jede Menge andere Leute, gerade hier im Berliner Umfeld, Friends and Family oder auch Durchreisende aus anderen Spaces dort vor Ort.
Aber wie ist die Gestehungsgeschichte der Raumfahrtagentur?
Also gleich vorweg, die Raumfahrtagentur ist, wie gerade schon erwähnt, der NYC Resistor als GmbH geflogen. Wir haben da eine Firma dafür gegründet. Konkret hab ich das alleine gemacht. Das ist ein Mann GmbH sozusagen.
Aber muss man nicht 5-stellig Geld auf einem Tisch legen?
Deswegen muss ich jetzt ein bisschen was zur Geschichte. Die Raumfahrtagentur gibt es seit 2008 hier in Berlin. Wir haben angefangen auf dem Prenzlauer Berg in der Metzerstraße. Das waren so knapp 90 Quadratmeter alte Arztpraxis im Erdgeschoss, die angemietet wurden. Es hat sich die besagte Firma, die SCNR GmbH, auch Ende November 2008 gegründet. In dem Jahr, wo die Räume angemietet wurden. Der Hintergrund war, dass sich ein paar Leute zusammengefunden haben, eben wegen dem Werkstattbedarf, eben wegen dem Interesse an Maschinen, an den Maschinenbetrieb, an den Maschinen dort aufzubauen. Das war zum größten Teil mein Thema, das bestand zu dem Zeitpunkt aus Elektrofahrrädern. Es ging um den Aufbau einer Werkstatt für E-Bikes, um irgendwie Elektrofahrzeuge zu bauen. Zum anderen Frank Krieger, es hat eingegangen mit einer CNC-Fresenanschaffung, dass man also eine Möglichkeit hat, sich eine größere CNC-Frise zu positionieren, was jetzt auch nicht in den bestehenden Spaces, geschweige denn zu Hause im Wohnzimmern möglich ist. Das waren noch so andere Interessensgruppen aus Textilarbeit. Ein bisschen die Etsy-Szene kam da ganz früh auf. Das waren die ersten Runden, da war eine Etsy. Und da hat sich also eine Gruppe von knapp zehn Leuten gefunden, die gesagt haben, okay, wir wollen so einen Space machen. Ich hatte mit dem Hintergrund Elektrofahrräder diese Firma gegründet und die Räume angemietet. Und so kamen die ersten Mitglieder zustande, die dann mit einem monatlichen Beitrag die Miete gestützt haben, dass man so viel zusammenbekommt, dass es viel Miete und Strom reicht.
Aber das ist quasi ein Business-Hintergrund, weil du wolltest eine Firma gründen, die dich mit E-Bikes beschäftigt. Und du hast dann Gleichgesinnte mehr oder weniger gefunden, die auch Interesse daran haben, einen Ort für ihr Geschäft zu haben.
Genau, die habe ich nicht gefunden.
Die kannte ich schon seit vielen Jahren.
Es ist hier direkt alles aus dem Umfeld des Chaos Computer Club, andere Interessierte und Nerds. Wir kannten uns alle zusammen schon eine ganze Weile. Und ich wurde vorgeschickt, einen Schuldiger muss den Mietvertrag unterschreiben.
Verstehe, dafür bist du jetzt. Kann einer von euch die Geschichte hier aus der Marienstraße 11 oder der Chaos Computer Club Berlin erzählen, wie es dazu kam?
Hauptsolange ist keiner von uns dabei. Aber wir können durchaus von anderen Spaces die Geschichte erzählen.
Oder anders gefragt. Das ist jetzt zwar ein Hackspace, aber er hätte nicht funktioniert, gäbe es nicht schon ordentlich Geld im Hintergrund, was daran liegt, dass Leute mit dem Geschäftstest umgegangen sind. Jetzt ist es in der Hackspace auch so was, da treffen sich einfach interessierte Leute, die vielleicht keine Kohle haben. Gibt es sowas auch, also quasi die andere Ecke, dass es das reine Wohnzimmer ist? Und wenn ja, wie macht man das?
Ich würd sogar sagen, das ist ein bisschen häufiger. Das ist eher ein Sonderfall, aber gibt's halt auch. Ist auch nicht schlechter. Aber es ist häufiger so, dass Leute sich zusammenfinden und sagen, wir brauchen ein Labor oder so. 1997 bin ich in Köln nach Raum gezogen und war total entsetzt, dass es dort keinen Chaos Computer Club gab. Dann haben wir uns mit mehreren Leuten zuerst wo getroffen, in einer Kneipe und so. Dann kam relativ schnell die Idee, wir brauchen nicht einen Treffpunkt in der Kneipe oder im Café. Sondern wir brauchen ein eigenes Labor. Den Begriff Hackerspace hatten wir damals noch nicht. Der kam irgendwann auf. Ich wüsste auch ganz gerne, wo der aufkam. In meiner Erinnerung war der einfach da.
Ich hab es auch nicht. Labor 23, die Geschichte aus Würzburg-Fuß in 2004. Da wäre Hackerspace auch nie so Thema gewesen.
Um 2006 oder so war der Begriff einfach da. Wir haben dann gesagt, wir brauchen Räumlichkeiten. Dann hat man gesucht. Das ist meistens die erste Phase, wenn man so einen Hackerspace gründet. Man braucht erst mal eine Menge von Leuten. Ich würde mal so sagen, so fünf Leute sind auch eine gute Zahl. Auf jeden Fall braucht man mehr als zwei. Meistens fängt es mit zwei an, die sich gegenseitig erzählen, wie toll das wäre, wenn man einen eigenen Raum hätte. Dann erweitert sich der Kreis langsam. Ab fünfen ist das langsam realistisch. Je höher es dann geht, desto besser wird es dann. Dann gibt es diese Voraussetzung für eine Vereinsgründung, was ganz gut ist, wenn man als Verein die Räumlichkeiten anmietet. Dann gibt es eine Phase, wo intensive Scouting betrieben wird.
Warte, warte, warte. Du musst dir vorstellen, jetzt hört jemand dieses Chaosradio und denkt so, dieses Hackerspace-Ding ist eigentlich total cool. Ich kenne auch ein paar Leute, die würden es auch gerne machen. Dann sagt jemand, ja, dann gründen wir einen Verein. Und dann suchen wir uns so, einen Verein gründen?
Was?
Was bedeutet das? Also für jemanden, der total unbelegt mit dem Thema ist.
Sieben Leute an einen Tisch setzen, sich irgendwie eine Satzung ausdenken oder vor allem sehr kopieren und den Namen austauschen. Darüber mal kurz abstimmen, ob man den Verein gründen möchte, unterschreiben, fertig, das Ganze nochmal ans Amt geben. Und dann hat man sogar einen Eingetragenen Verein.
Also bei allen Vereinsgründungen, wo ich dabei war, wurde eigentlich die Satzung des Chaos Computer Clubs genommen. Und mit suchen und ersetzen...
Okay, werden wir den Shownotes bitte auch verlinken? Die Satzung des Chaos Computer Clubs? Damit man die sich abschreien kann?
Und dann auch wieder interessante Sachen. Also soweit ich weiß, ist der Chaos Computer Club nicht gemeinnützig, aber in Köln hatten wir dann auch noch so...
Die Struktur hatten wir ja historisch, die Airfars im CCC-Bereich existieren schon länger. Da ist das Konzept auch schon üblich, dass die Vereinssatzung entsprechend kopiert wird.
Ja, in Köln hat man dann halt wegen... Also in Köln liebt man halt so seine Vereine, die Brauchtumspflege, die Völkerverständigung etc. Das war dann halt auch relativ einfach, das dann als gemeinnützig anzuerkennen.
Okay, also das bringt dann irgendwie geldwerte Vorteile? Oder warum will man gemeinnützig werden?
Na, erstmal hat man eine juristische Person. Die juristische Person kann das Konto führen, kann auch den Mietvertrag führen. Man kann sich dann halt sowas wie eine demokratische Struktur geben, dass man halt erstmal so einen Vorstand vorgeschrieben hat, der gewählt werden muss etc. Das bringt schon alles unterm Strich wahrscheinlich mehr Vorteile als Nachteile.
Okay, aber das heißt sozusagen, es ist halt nicht damit getan, dass man sich irgendwo in eine Raumfilm-Sache geile setzt, sondern das scheint so eine Art Minimum zu sein, dass man so eine Vereinsgründung hinter sich bringt, was zumindest ein bisschen Bürokratie nachzutreten, oder?
Das bietet sich irgendwie an, auch irgendwie von der Nachhaltigkeit. Gerade wenn Leute dann irgendwie wegziehen oder einfach kein Interesse mehr an dem Projekt haben, dann hat man halt irgendwie eine juristische Person, die das weiterführt. Aber es ist überhaupt nicht Voraussetzung. Also es kann man halt auch irgendwie sagen, wir sind drei Leute, wir schmeißen Geld zusammen, wir suchen uns einen Raum, das geht auch.
Okay, aber es ist ja gut zu sagen, so was vorher zu wissen. Ich hab mal ein Förderungsprojekt gehabt und da hat möglicherweise vorher jemand gesagt, du musst pro Monat zwei extra Tage einrechnen, nur für den Bürokram, der dadurch anfällt. Wie aufwendig ist so eine Vereinsgründung?
Die Gründung ist sehr schnell, aber der Betrieb ist vereins. Der braucht halt ein bisschen Pflege. Also man kann es auf Minimum reduzieren, dass man halt wirklich nur so schaut, dass die Mitgliedsbeiträge von den Mitgliedern halt einfach reinkommen, dass darüber dann ein Konto geführt wird, dass das dann irgendwann einmal im Jahr zusammengefasst wird, auch dann zum Finanzamt gebracht wird. Das war's dann fast auch schon. Also es ist kein großer Akt, um das zu führen.
Okay, gut. Dann wissen wir jetzt schon mal, was ein Hackerspace ist und was man sozusagen minimal, also am besten hat man jemand, der eine Firma gründet, und da geht's schneller mit einem Tag und man muss nicht mit sieben Leuten fahren.
Mich würde aber auch noch mal die Perspektive von Cat interessieren, weil ihr ganz frisch drin seid.
Moment, Moment, Moment. Das machen wir. Haunted, hauntet, hallo, hallo. Könnten wir vielleicht ein bisschen Sound bekommen? Hallo, hallo. Chaos Radio 2022, die Sendung mit der Sendelücke. Das war Haunted House von Plastic Angel of the Months. Ein ganz cooles Musikprojekt, wie ich finde, weil deren Plan ist es jeden Monat die komplette Besetzung auszutauschen, dann eine neue EP zu produzieren. Das kann man auch mal machen, finde ich. Ihr seid im Chaos Radio 222, das live aus der Marienstraße 11 gesendet wird und die Marienstraße 11 ist der Sitz des Chaos Computer Clubs Berlin und ein Hackspace und genau darum soll die Sendung heute gehen. Wir haben schon in der ersten halben Stunde ein bisschen gehört, was ist denn jetzt eigentlich so ein Hackspace? Was kann man da machen? Was ist der Unchitter im Fab Lab? Und was braucht man denn, wenn man so ein Ding selber gründen will? Und das kann uns jetzt vielleicht ganz genau erzählen. Unter anderem Cat, die heute hier ist. Hallo und herzlich willkommen noch mal zurück. Und du bist Teil eines Teams, das gerade einen Hackspace gründet.
Das ist richtig.
Es gibt doch schon genug.
Naja, wir machen halt einen Hackspace für Frauen. Das wird jetzt ein bisschen anders als die Hackspaces, die es schon in Berlin gibt. Warum das anders wird? Naja, wir haben da irgendwie so einen Bedarf gesehen. Es gibt so eine Diskrepanz zwischen den Frauen, die an Technik interessiert sind und den Frauen, die tatsächlich in technischen Berufen arbeiten oder in Hackspaces gehen oder technische Sachen studieren. Und so ein bisschen festgestellt, dass wenn man diese Frauen einlädt und Angebote schafft, dass die dann kommen. Und es gibt so einen riesigen Bedarf. Und es gibt viele Initiativen in Berlin, die sich speziell an Frauen richten, wie zum Beispiel die Rails Girls, die Pie Ladies, Enclosure Bridge und jetzt auch uns. Und unsere Angebote sind total überlaufen. Also wir haben teilweise dreimal mehr Anmeldungen als wir überhaupt Plätze in den Workshops haben. Also es gibt halt einen riesen Bedarf und den muss man einfach adressieren.
Und das heißt also im Prinzip, es gibt schon diese Veranstaltung und ihr macht jetzt einen Ort, damit die da stattfinden können?
Ganz genau. Also wir haben auch so klassisch angefangen, wie Joel das beschreibt. Wir waren einfach irgendwie ein paar Freundinnen und haben gedacht, hey, das wäre doch cool, wenn wir unseren eigenen Space hätten. Und es ist nicht jemand, die Stichsäge aus der Hand nimmt, wenn wir gerade was sehen wollen, weil wir das ja auch selber können. Und dann haben wir erst mal in unseren eigenen Netzwerken, weil es gibt ja viele Frauen in der Hacker Szene auch in Berlin in unseren Netzwerken irgendwie so eine Mail rumgeschickt und gesagt so, hey, guck mal, wir hatten Bock, so einen Space zu gründen, wollte nicht irgendwie mitmachen. Und das hat dann sehr schnell ziemlich große Kreise geschlagen. Und wir hatten dann in einem Monat 300 Leute irgendwie in unserer Mailing Liste. Und dann haben wir halt angefangen, uns zu treffen und haben auch ganz viele andere Hackerspaces besucht und die gefragt, wie die das so gemacht haben mit der Gründung und mit der Vereinsgründung und mit der Finanzierung und wie man es irgendwie am besten macht. Und dann haben wir das alles zusammengetragen und gedacht, gut, das machen wir jetzt. Und dann haben wir ja im Januar, weil wir jetzt noch keinen eigenen Space haben, angefangen Workshops zu geben, anzubieten, irgendwie zu Datenvisualisierung oder auch so Einsteiger-Workshops, damit irgendwie auch Frauen die Chance gibt, überhaupt erst in diese Szene reinzukommen, die es vielleicht interessiert, aber noch nicht so dabei sind. Oder eine Crypto-Party haben wir auch gemacht, die auch ziemlich überlaufen war. Und das dann in so befreundeten Spaces, also zum Beispiel bei Wikimedia und bei Posteo, die haben uns ihr Lab zur Verfügung gestellt und die Open Knowledge Foundation. Ja, und jetzt inzwischen gibt es gerade einen anderen neuen Hackspace, der sich gründet in Friedrichshain, das ist Xhain, den Pilon auch schon erwähnt hat. Und Felix vom Xhain ist auf uns zugekommen und hat gesagt, hey, wir machen einen neuen Space, wollt ihr nicht irgendwie zu uns kommen einen Tag die Woche? Und jetzt haben wir erst mal, bis wir einen eigenen Space haben, jeden Donnerstag da einen Damensalon im Xhain, wo wir irgendwie abhängen und auch abends Veranstaltungen machen. Genau, und so weit sind wir gerade.
Aber jetzt hast du gerade gesagt, im Januar ging es schon los, es ist ja mittlerweile fast schon Mai und wir haben ja gerade schon gehört, naja, im Prinzip ist es ganz einfach, man setzt sich um den Tisch, füllt ein Vereinsformular aus und dann geht es los. Ihr plant das nun mal größer oder was hält euch noch auf?
Na ja, es ist halt die Finanzierung so ein bisschen. Das Ding ist, wenn man in Berlin so ein Space aufmachen will, dann hast du einmal ganz krasse Mietkosten. Es ist einfach so in Berlin, es ist halt richtig teuer, wenn du irgendwie selbst einen relativ kleinen Space, so kleiner als hier irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, 80 Quadratmeter oder so, zahlst du halt über 1, 5 Miete und dann kommt da noch Strom und Internet und Serverkosten und all sowas dazu und dann hast du noch einmalig die Einrichtung, was ja auch extrem teuer ist, vor allem wenn man noch Geräte haben will, wie einen 3D-Drucker und Hardware-Kram und vielleicht einen Laser-Cutter und das muss man erst mal irgendwoher kriegen, das Geld.
Eine Bank überfallen.
Ja, also wir wollten Schnaps verkaufen am 1. Mai in Kreuzberg. Also wir haben so ein paar verschiedene Finanzierungsprojekte. Also es wurde irgendwie ein bisschen abgeraten von öffentlichen Geldern, weil das so viel Arbeit mit sich bringt. Jetzt haben wir aber auch zwei Mädels dabei, die sagen, wir machen das beruflich auch, uns mit öffentlichen Geldern auseinanderzusetzen. Wir können da mal gucken. Also da haben wir irgendwie so eine Taskforce, die sich ein bisschen darum kümmert. Dann haben wir jetzt uns überlegt, vielleicht machen wir einfach eine Crowdfunding Kampagne, weil das ist so am einfachsten und da sind wir jetzt gerade dran. Und das stehen ganz gut in den Startlöchern. Also ich glaube, das wird dann vielleicht letztendlich unser Mittel der Wahl, um erstmal irgendwie so ein Startkapital zu kriegen. Und eine andere Option, die wir in Betracht gezogen haben, war auch so ein Sponsoring von Firmen. Aber es war sehr schwierig, Firmen zu finden, mit denen wir ideologisch übereinstimmen und die aber auch Geld haben, um uns zu sponsern.
Das alte Problem.
Richtig.
Aber wie groß soll das Budget sein? Also wie groß muss die Summe sein, wenn ihr sagt, okay, das reicht, jetzt fangen wir an?
Ja, also wir haben uns überlegt, wir hätten gerne irgendwie so eine einigermaßen stabile Finanzierung für die ersten zwei Jahre, damit wir genug Zeit haben, um so eine Memberbase aufzubauen, sodass wir nach zwei Jahren genug Member haben, um unabhängig und alleine zu finanzieren. Und haben jetzt mal so überschlagen, dass man da vielleicht so 70.000 Euro braucht für zwei Jahre.
Holy shit. Ist das nur, weil es in Berlin ist und weil da noch eine Leserkarte rein soll? Oder ist das generell eine Summe, wo man sagt, also wenn ihr ein Hackerspace machen wollt, der irgendwie so ein bisschen funktioniert, dann braucht man so viel Geld?
Also ich glaube, wenn man in Krastorp-Rauksel wohnt, ist es wahrscheinlich ein bisschen billiger. Dann kann man sich halt für 100 Euro irgendeine Halle mieten. Also ich glaube, ein ganz großer Teil dieses Budgets ist die Miete.
Es ist so ein bisschen organisches Wachstum. Also die Hackerspaces oder Hackerspaces, Makerspaces, die ich so mitgesehen habe, die gewachsen sind, die groß geworden sind, die haben auch klein angefangen mit so einer kleinen Runde von fünf Leuten, vielleicht wie ich jetzt vorhin schon mal sagte, sind dann schnell gewachsen. Das heißt, mit ein paar wenigen Leuten kann man sagen, ich schmeiße jetzt irgendwie im Monat mein Ding, meine 100 Euro rein und dann haben wir 500 pro Monat zusammen, dann können wir schon mal unsere 50 Quadratmeter anmieten oder 30 oder sonst wie auch immer. Schon mal damit anfangen, um dann halt hinter zu expandieren. Ich kenne genügend Spaces, die innerhalb der ersten drei bis fünf Jahre fünfmal umgezogen sind, immer wieder etwas größere Räume rein, bis dann hinterher irgendwann vielleicht noch fünf Jahren auch zu Bekanntheit da ist, dass vielleicht auch ein bisschen Support da ist, sodass sich jemand sagt, ich hab da eh eine leere Halle, ich mach einen Freundschaftspreis dafür, der könnte quasi mit reinkommen und könnte diese Halle nutzen, dann hat er 500 Quadratmeter.
Aber wie ist das, wenn ich jetzt sozusagen anfangen will, so ein Ding aufzumachen, ist es dann sinnvoll, dass man sagt, also wenn man jetzt nicht sozusagen ein Geschäft gleich mit drin hat, ist es dann sinnvoll zu sagen, wir machen erstmal so klein wie möglich, damit wir nicht auf die Nase fallen, oder ist es so, dass er sagt, nee, es macht schon Sinn, das gleich von Anfang an eine Nummer größer zu planen, weil sonst kann es nie sozusagen so attraktiv werden, dass überhaupt andere Leute damit dazu wollen.
Man muss ein bisschen auf den Ort schauen. Also Berlin ist glaube ich fast schon ein schlechter Ort, um noch einen neuen Space aufzumachen. Wir haben schon irgendwie 17, 18 Hackspaces in der Stadt. Das ist glaube ich die Stadt weltweit mit den meisten Hackspaces. Vielleicht auch erst mal schauen, was gibt es schon vor Ort? Kann ich vielleicht was supporten auch, um dort größer zu werden? Oder wenn ich wirklich neu aufmachen möchte, dann klein anfangen gucken, dann größer zu werden. Das ist eigentlich schon fast der bessere Weg. Wenn es irgendwann scheitert, wenn man merkt, nach zwei Jahren, das war jetzt alles nichts irgendwie, wir müssen den ganzen Maschinenpark wieder rausschmeißen und so, dann liegt man jetzt nicht irgendwie auf einem großen Batzen Geld, den man irgendwie noch mal nachzahlen muss.
Ist eigentlich eine Vereinsabwicklung, wo wir gerade dabei sind, kompliziert? Oder setzen sich die sieben Leute einfach wieder an den Tisch und sagen, so, das war's?
Ich wüsste jetzt noch von keinem Hackspace, wo wir zurückwickeln, abwickeln mussten. Also ich kenne keinen, die existieren alle irgendwie immer noch.
Cold Deaths friert dann meistens ein und verschwindet. Cold Deaths verschwindet dann in der Zeit des Fritt ein. Und ich glaube, es gibt da gar nicht so viel.
Aber die Vereinsabwicklung, die hast du tatsächlich in deiner Satzung mit drin, kann man sich auch kopieren. Das ist so meist der letzte Paragraph, der in der Absatzung drin steht. Was passiert bei Auflösung eines Vereins, wenn alle dafür stimmen oder die Großmehrheit dafür, dann steht auch, wo halt zum Beispiel das Geld hin wandert und so weiter und so fort. Das ist alles geregelt.
Sehr gut.
Jetzt wurde aber gesagt, also das war mich ein bisschen wundert, weil einerseits man braucht also viel Geld, um anzufangen. Also relativ zumindest. Andererseits so öffentliche Fördermittel eher nicht. Aber da denkt man sich doch, also gerade wenn man jetzt ein mittelloser Hacker ist und so ein bisschen was für die Infrastruktur im Ort auch tun will und vielleicht so eine Art Bildungsprogramm ja auch anbietet, warum nicht öffentliche Mittel? Dafür sind sie doch da oder nicht?
Bei all diesen Finanzierungsmodellen kann man halt irgendwie mit einem total definitiven Kommt-drauf-an das irgendwie festmachen. Also es gibt halt, es gibt halt irgendwie fast für jedes Modell, also auch für öffentliche Mittel oder so gibt es irgendwie erfolgreiche Modelle, wo Leute das durchgemacht haben. Es ist halt ein bisschen schwierig, also man hat dann irgendwie dieses ganze Reporting und man ist dann eingeschränkt und so weiter. Das passt meistens nicht zu der Arbeitsweise von Leuten, die einfach nur Labor für Freies herumschweben haben wollen. Das ist dann oft halt irgendwie sehr auf die Sache bezogen. Ich höre aber auch irgendwie mit totalem Interesse zu, also wie ihr das jetzt aufzieht. Also wir hatten halt damals irgendwie so den Plan von der Finanzierung. Also wir sind irgendwie wirtschaftlich total gut aufgestellt, wenn wir eine Monatsmiete noch auf dem Konto haben. Und dass wir dann halt irgendwie im Zweifelsfall den Space noch einen Monat weiterlaufen lassen. Ja, das kommt halt einfach aus einer anderen Zeit. Auch irgendwie, wenn man sieht, hier die ganzen imposanten Hackerspaces in Berlin, hier Marienstraße 11 oder Seabase oder so, die kommen halt auch aus einer Zeit, als es noch andere Mieten in Berlin gab. Das ist vielleicht auch ein Faktor.
Also ich hab gerade hier, um das kurz einzufichten, mir wurde gerade noch geflüstert, dass die Anfänge des Clubs hier auch darin begründet liegen, dass die Wohnungsbauagentur damals dachte, ach so ein paar Dinge, können wir doch hier mal ein paar Gebäude, die gerade leer stehen, irgendwie vergeben. Und das war dann sozusagen natürlich noch einfacher, einen Platz zu finden.
Zum Beispiel, ich glaube auch, die C-Base hat irgendwie sowas gemacht und da gab es halt eine Frau im Magistrat, die gesagt hat, hier soll halt auch noch in die Kulturförderung gehen und so weiter. Das sind natürlich irgendwie Sachen, die kann man nicht darauf spekulieren, dass man irgendwie einen Staat hat, der pleite gilt und deswegen Räume zur Verfügung stehen.
Sehr gut, aber man kann natürlich so fragen, kostet nichts, oder?
Ja, in vielen Fällen ist es auch einfach so, Leute sagen, ich hab einen Raum und die Räume kommen irgendwo her.
Also falls jemand einen Raum für uns hat, kann er sich gerne bei uns melden.
Die Raumsuche ist einer der spannenden Elemente, man muss schon was passendes finden. Es ist manchmal doch ein bisschen spezieller, auch die Anforderungen und es ist nicht so einfach nur möglich, jeden beliebigen zu nehmen. Zum anderen Erfahrung, da ist das Hackerspaces auch recht skurril sind und mitunter in recht skurrilen Räumen unterkommen, wo so normale Veranstaltungen, normale Sachen nicht so richtig denkbar wäre. Alte Solarien in liegen gebliebenen städtischen Schwimmwädern von vor 30 Jahren. Zum Beispiel. Nicht schlecht.
Alte Brausefabrik, die fällt mir noch in Köln ein. Oder eine Gasmotorenfabrik gab es da auch mal.
Tabakfabrik in Würzburg, richtig spät.
Aber allein schon diese Raumsuche und diese ganze Verwaltung da drumherum ist schon Hacking an sich hart. Kann man auch schon so nehmen. Man muss ein bisschen kreativ damit umgehen, oftmals bei Städten, wo man halt neu dabei ist. Und dann kommt man hin und sagt so, hey, wir wollen hier einen Hackerspace gründen. Die haben wir schon in unserer Zung und unser Verein dafür. Und dann gucken die einen blöd an, so, in was? Und da dauert dann halt auch mit reinzugehen. Ich meine, Sportverein kennt jeder oder ein Taumzüchterverein und so weiter. Aber was ist ein Hackerspace, die sich als Verein organisieren und dort dann halt auch kreativ mit umgehen? Ja, guck mal, hier bei Sportverein könntest du auch so machen. Warum geht das bei uns nicht? Wir machen auch das gleiche so Hack Sport. Das geht doch alles da mit rein.
Okay, wir sind jetzt noch die Runde noch eins erweitern. Und zwar schalten wir jetzt ins Raumzeitlabor. Ist dort jemand zu hören? Hallo, mit wem spreche ich denn jetzt?
Ein bisschen irritierend, weil ich mich selbst mit Verzögerung auf meinen Ohren höre.
Audio Technik ist so ein großartiges Ding, wenn es mal funktioniert. Manchmal tut es auch nicht. Sollen wir das noch mal versuchen zu fixen oder schaffst du es trotzdem mit uns zu sprechen?
Ich denke das gleich hin.
Sehr gut. Dann erzähl doch mal ein bisschen, was ist denn, wir haben schon verschiedene Sorten von Hackerspace gehört. Was ist denn das Raumzeitlabor für eine? Und vor allen Dingen, wo genau?
Wir sind in Mannheim. Und wir sind ein normaler Hackerspace.
Was heißt normaler Hackerspace?
Ja, so normal wie es halt sein kann.
Das heißt ein Raum, in dem zwei Stahlträger durch die Decke gestemmt sind, wo Sofas drinstehen, wo ein Kabeltisch drinsteht.
Das kommt ganz gut hin. Also im Wikipedia Artikel Hackerspace war eine ganze Weile lang ein Bild vom Raumzeitlabor. Ich weiß nicht, ob der da auch immer ist. Ich weiß auch nicht, wer das hinbekommen hat.
Wie habt ihr den gegründet? Wir haben schon verschiedene Sachen gehört, wie man Hackerspaces gründet. Wie kam es zum Raumzeitlabor?
Das ist eine sehr lange Geschichte.
Könnten wir die Management-Zusammenfassung in drei Minuten haben?
Die Management-Zusammenfassung ist, dass es eine Aufspaltung vom CCC Mannheim gab, die dann in einem anderen EV gegründet hat und zusammen mit noch weiteren Vereinen hier in der Region, unter anderem dem Chaos of Heidelberg und der Unix User Group Rhein-Neckar, wollten wir dann eben einen Raum gemeinsam. Und um diesen Raum anzumieten, wie man das macht, wie das ja schon besprochen wurde in der Runde, gründet man einen Verein und das war das Raumzeitlabor.
Und wie habt ihr jetzt ganz konkret den Raum gefunden, in dem ihr jetzt seid? Also wie seid ihr da rangekommen?
Das weiß ich gar nicht mehr genau. Also einer von uns hatte irgendwie einen Bekannten, der in diesem Gebäude schon einen kleinen Raum so als Atelier gemietet hatte. Also letztendlich sind wir auf so einem ehemaligen Industriegelände, ja über so einer Lagehalle. Also es sind tatsächlich Stahlträger und alles im Raum.
Ist euer Hackspace ein offener Hackspace, wo jeder hinkommen kann oder seid ihr eine geschlossene Gesellschaft?
Klar ist ja ein. Der Raum an sich ist natürlich jedem offen, nur da wir auf so einem Privatgelände von so einer Schwerlast-Spedition sind, ist es gar nicht so einfach zu uns zu finden. Also sprich, wenn man da nach Feierabend der Spedition hin will, dann sind Tore zu, da sind Pin-Codes und all so ein Zeug.
Das ist doch nur so eine Art Herausforderung für den angehenden Hacker, oder?
Ja genau, das sagen wir auch. Das ist der erste Test.
Die Frage ist dann, wie sich auch verschiedene Hackspaces voneinander unterscheiden. Was ist denn am Raumzeitlabor Besonderes, was es vielleicht von anderen Hackspaces unterscheidet? Oder ist es einfach nur der Hackspace in Mannheim?
Ich würde sagen, es ist der Hackspace in Mannheim. Ob das jetzt nur, ob das das richtige Wort ist.
Naja, also im Sinne, dass er sich nicht von anderen Hackspaces unterscheidet.
Die offene Küche.
Ja, also Details gibt es natürlich, wo wir uns unterscheiden. Wir haben halt einen Raum, der 4, 30 Meter hoch ist. Deswegen habe ich gesagt, den kann man ja nutzen, den Raum. Mein Vater ist Zimmermeister. Und dann haben wir da halt so eine zweite Eben aus Holz reingezimmert. Also natürlich unterscheidet es sich von allen anderen Hacker Spaces, wie sich jeder von jedem unterscheidet. Aber so jetzt was ganz Besonderes, was unbedingt das Raumzeitlabor ausmacht.
Okay, ich würde jetzt gerne zum nächsten Thema übergehen und dann Tabasko gleich am Anfang mal fragen, wie das bei denen ist. Und zwar das Ding ist, Hackspaces sind ja Gemeinschaften von Menschen. Das muss ja so sein. Das macht ja keinen Sinn. Wir haben schon gehört, also zwei mindestens, besser fünf, wahrscheinlich eher sieben, damit man einen Verein gründen kann. Wenn jetzt Menschen zusammenkommen und dann auch noch eine gemeinsame Verantwortung haben für einen Ort, dann müssen ja irgendwie Entscheidungen getroffen werden. Und die Frage ist, wie macht man das? Und vor allen Dingen, wie macht man das so, dass man sich nicht nach zwei Wochen die Köpfe zusammenschlägt? Wie macht ihr das denn im Raumzeitlabor? Gibt es da, habt ihr sozusagen, also wenn Entscheidungen getroffen werden müssen, so was wie wir bauen da noch ein Ding ein oder wer darf als nächstes mit den Pin-Code im Tor kaputt machen? Also wie genau entscheidet ihr Dinge, die euch alle betreffen?
Na ja, die meiste Zeit hatten wir diese übliche Maxime, wer macht hat recht. Das trägt natürlich nur bis zu einem gewissen Grad, also wenn ich jetzt denke, ich sprühe alles schwarz mit schwarzer Farbe an, weil ich sage, wer macht hat Recht, dann funktioniert das natürlich nicht.
Und was macht ihr dann?
So eine Situation hatten wir eigentlich noch nicht. Also so ein Extremes.
Nein, ich meine nicht sozusagen, wenn jemand euch den Raum anschaut, sondern wenn ihr sagt, okay, es ist eine Entscheidung, die jetzt alle betrifft, die müssen wir treffen. Wie trefft ihr die da?
Wir haben einmal im Monat ein Plenum. Damit entscheiden wir zumindest so Sachen wie Geld ausgeben.
Und das funktioniert problemlos?
Ach Gott, es gibt natürlich Diskussionen. Warum müssen wir jetzt eine Stickmaschine für 5000 Euro kaufen?
Warum nicht?
Richtig.
Na gut, Tabasko, vielen Dank für die Einblicke ins Raumzeitlabor. Noch mal, falls jemand aus Mannheim gerade zuhört und sie sehen, man, da würde ich eigentlich auch gerne mal vorbeigucken. Aber wie man so einen PIN-Code aufmacht, weiß ich jetzt noch nicht. Wie macht man das am besten? Euch kontaktieren oder vielleicht mal vorbeikommen können?
Auf unserer Webseite gibt es eine detaillierte Anfahrtsbeschreibung. Die empfehlen wir eben auch jedem. Es kommen aber trotzdem immer Leute, die sagen, wir sind eine Stunde am suchen. Dann meinen wir mal, habt ihr die Anfahrtsbeschreibung gelesen?
Aber Uhrzeit egal, Tageszeit egal? Oder gibt es sozusagen, wo ihr sagt, an dem Tag ist es besonders gut, mal vorbeizukommen?
Ganz im Sinne der Hackerspace Design Patterns treffen wir uns natürlich dienstags. Da ist der öffentliche Tag, obwohl alle Tage so gesehen öffentlich sind. Aber die Leute wollen halt immer einen Tag, der definiert ist.
Okay, alles klar. Dann vielen Dank und viel Spaß hier noch an Mannheim. Danke. So, jetzt fiel dir gerade das Wort Hackerspace Design Pattern. Das klingt mir so ein bisschen wie das kleine Handbuch des Hackerspaces. Was genau ist das? Wo kann man es finden? Und warum erfahre ich erst jetzt davon? Alle zeigen auf Pylorn. Pylorn scheint Bescheid zu wissen.
Nee, nee, der Joel ist schuld hier. Wir können es gemeinsam auch sagen. Hackerspace Design Patterns. Dann hast du vielleicht im Jahr 2007 geschlafen, Markus.
Das ist gut möglich, ich schlafe sehr gerne.
Sehr gut. Hackerspace Design Patterns, wie kam das zustande? 2007 war ein Jahr, da war das Chaos Communication Camp. Damals noch in Vierindorford gewesen, vom CTC halt ausgerichtet.
Also Sommerveranstaltungen eine Woche lang.
Genau, da gab es dann auch irgendwie alle vier Jahre leider nur, gibt dann auch andere Camps zwischendurch, andere Veranstaltungen. Da gab es dann so eine Gruppe von Leuten aus den USA, die kamen rübergeflogen, so Hackers on a Plane, so schön irgendwie gemeinsam rüberfliegen. Und die haben dann gesagt, so ja, wir machen jetzt noch mal irgendwie eine Woche oder zwei länger in Deutschland, Österreich. Und wir gucken jetzt mal dort so die Räume an. Wir haben ja gehört, der CCC und andere Gruppen haben ganz tolle viele Räume. Und wir wollen sowas auch in den USA haben. Wie habt ihr das geschafft, das aufzubauen? Und haben dann gefragt, so ja, komm, wir fahren jetzt mal rum. Wir sind an dem, dem Tag, in dem, dem Raum, in dem, dem Hackerspace. Und macht doch mal eine Präsentation, wie ihr diese Räume aufgebaut habt und wie ihr die unterhaltet, damit wir das so ein bisschen kopieren können quasi.
Es war eigentlich eine ganz lustige Gruppe, die da unterwegs war. Da war ja Dan Kaminski dabei, irgendwie ein bekannter Sicherheitsforscher. Brie Pettis, der damals beim Make Magazine gearbeitet hat. Und Nick Farr. Nick Farr ist so ein bisschen so der, der Pate der Hackerspace Bewegung in den USA lang geworden. Und war auch lange Jahre auf dem CCC-Kongress. Irgendwie ist einigen vielleicht bekannt, dass er da irgendwie anmoderiert hat und so weiter. Irgendwie ein ganz, ganz quirliger Typ im Anzug. Und die waren alle von der Frage irgendwie beseelt. So irgendwie, wie machen die Europäer das? Warum kommt es eigentlich dazu, dass das halt eigentlich die Hacker Bewegung kommt aus den USA? Aber hat sich da nie verfangen können? Natürlich gab es da immer Hacker, auch Leute, die sich da in Gruppen getroffen haben. Aber sowas Nachhaltiges wie den CCC gab es da schon mal gar nicht. Das dümpelte auch alles irgendwie sehr auf so einer Untergrundschiene rum. Also sehr viele unangenehme Situationen mit Polizei etc. Kriminalisierung, nur weil man sich halt irgendwie für unkonventionelle Techniknutzung interessiert. Und sowas wie feste Räumlichkeiten gab es immer schon da auch. Es gibt einen Ort, der heißt das Loft in Boston, also mit Null und pH geschrieben Loft. Und ja, aber irgendwie sind die dann alle immer verschwunden nach einer Zeit. Und da hat sich dann auch niemand gefunden, dieses Space weiterzuführen. Und wir hatten halt zu dem Zeitpunkt ja Jahrzehnte Erfahrung, kann man eigentlich schon sagen. Also CCC Köln, den sie dann besucht haben, den gab es da zu dem Zeitpunkt zehn Jahre lang. Und die Räumlichkeiten hier in Berlin, die gab es noch viel länger.
Ja, dann kam ja Jens irgendwie, wir waren beide damals in Köln, auch im CCC Köln, auch aktiv. Dann kam Jens auf mich zu, meinte so, hey, die kommen jetzt da an dem Tag vorbei. Ich glaube, das war ein Dienstag eventuell. Wir sollen einen Vortrag halten, wie läuft das eigentlich mit den Hackerspaces? Aber lassen wir nicht über den CCC Köln reden, sondern lassen wir was Allgemeines draus machen. Man hat den Vorschlag gemacht, so einen Designpattern-Kanalog aufzustellen. Designpattern sind schon ein bisschen älter, ursprünglich aus Architektur entstanden. Ich will eine Satellitenstadt aufbauen. Was brauche ich alles in einer Satellitenstadt? Okay, ich brauche Wohnhäuser, ich brauche irgendwie Schulen. Und das halt so als Fragestellung, als Problemstellung mit einer möglichen Antwort oder mehreren möglichen Antworten. So, irgendwo die Fragestellung ist, wo gehen die Leute einkaufen? Antwort, ja gut, ich bau dann halt ein paar Supermärkte dahin. Fragestellung, die Kinder sollen irgendwie spielen? Ja, ich bau einen Kindergarten und ich bau noch irgendwie Spielplätze dazu.
Genau, das ist ein bisschen anders als ein Kochrezept. Also was ich halt irgendwie Schritt für Schritt befolge. Und am Schluss hab ich ein Ergebnis. So ein Designpattern-Katalog ist eigentlich mehr so eine Art Lego-Kiste, wo ich mir einzelne Teile rausnehmen kann und die passen alle ineinander. Aber was ich dann letztendlich damit baue, das ist dann mir überlassen. Aber die Teile an sich müssen alle irgendwie passen. Und da muss halt irgendwie Erfahrung bei sein. Und wir haben dann angefangen und uns voll in diese Metapher reingesteigert. Und das ist immer schön, wenn man eine Metapher hat, die man bis zum Schluss auskosten kann. Und haben dann halt angefangen, diesen Designpattern-Katalog für den Aufbau von Hackerspaces zu machen. Und da fielen uns dann gleich ein paar Sachen ein, die wir einfach in den letzten zehn Jahren gelernt und gemacht haben. Zum Beispiel das Plenum-Pattern. Wir haben gesagt, es ist irgendwie gut, wenn du ein regelmäßiges Plenum hast, wo du über Themen dann halt entscheiden kannst und dich abschnimmen kannst.
Ich kam auch bei RUM irgendwie so, ja, aber wann treffen wir uns denn? Und ganz allgemein gesagt, jeder Wochentag ist blöd, nimm den Dienstag. Das steht einfach so da drin und das wurde eins zu eins von, ich weiß nicht, wie viele Spaces kopiert. Man findet es auch heute immer noch, schau einfach mal irgendwie Hackerspace in den USA an, wie viele sich da Dienstags treffen. Das ist der alte Tenor halt aus dem CCC auch gewesen, als das CCC eigene Gruppen aufgemacht hatte. Wenn wir uns alle Dienstag treffen, dann können wir auch Telefonkonferenzen machen und uns mal untereinander auch absprechen. Man weiß ja, dass in einem anderen Raum irgendwo jemand ist. Wir haben das einfach mal komplett so mit übernommen. Es ist heute bei vielen Spaces immer noch so, vielleicht Ausnahme Berlin, weil es gibt so viele Spaces und einige Leute mehrere Spaces besuchen, dass dann auch in mehreren Tagen dann halt treffen ist. Aber hier am CCCB ist jeden Dienstag offen, da könnt ihr auch vorbeikommen.
Ich wollte mal ganz kurz fragen, habt ihr euch dieses Design-Pattern-Ding jetzt auch vorgenommen und befolgt es genau oder macht ihr?
Ne, wir haben tatsächlich viele Leute interviewt und befragt, wie sie ihre Spaces aufgebaut haben, wie sie es gemacht haben.
Okay, gut, ich möchte gleich nochmal genauer auf diese Entscheidungsfindung und Problemlösungsstrategien zwischenmenschlich auch in Hackspaces zurückkommen. Aber vorher machen wir noch eine kleine musikalische Pause, die mit einem kulturellen Ereignis zu tun hat, das gerade wieder angefangen hat und danach gibt es die NerdNews. Kelly Maisy war das In the Night, ein Game of Thrones Remake, wie man sicherlich gehört hat. Diese Song ist auch ein kleines, spannendes Lehrstück in der EU bei Rechtskultur, weil in den Amerika, in den USA ist das Fair Use. Das heißt, da darf man das machen und diese Musik schickt, das wir gerade gehört haben, das Creative Convincence. Und das habe ich als Vorwort genommen, um es hier in Deutschland abzuspielen. Ich weiß nicht ganz, ob ein Jurist mir da irgendwie zustimmen würde, aber ich habe gedacht, das geht vielleicht mal. So, wir sind hier im Chaosradio 222 und wie es sich für ein ordentliches Chaosradio gehört, gibt es natürlich jetzt mal die Nerd-News und die sind zusammengetragen von Danima und vorgetragen von Christina.
Unbekannte haben per Mailware unbemerkt 80 Millionen US-Dollar aus der Zentralbank von Bangladesch gestohlen. Denn digital hatte die Bug nicht viel aufzubieten, um Einbrüche zu verhindern. Auch vollständig nachvollziehen ließ sich die Attacke nicht. So fanden Gutachter in der Bug 10 Dollar Gebrauch-Twitches und monierten das Fehlen jeglicher Firewalls. Ein größerer Schaden wurde nur verhindert, weil sich die Ganoven bei einem Empfänger vertippten und Kreditinstitut TUTU so bei der Zentralbank nachfragen mussten. Diese stornierte dann die Überweisungen, die sie sonst um eine Milliarde US-Dollar erleichtert hätten. Ob man die verbliebenen Millionen nun in ein vernünftiges Sicherheitskonzept investiert, ist nicht bekannt. Der Browser-Hersteller Opera bietet erstmalig ab Werk einen gebündelten, kostenlosen VPN-Dienst an. Im aktuellen Developer-Bild lässt sich der Browser so konfigurieren, dass Webseiten den Anwender als Nutzer aus Deutschland, den USA oder Kanada wahrnehmen. Die Daten werden nach Angaben des Unternehmens im VPN-Tunnel verschlüsselt. Der Dienst wird durch den VPN-Anbieter SurfEasy realisiert, den Opera im letzten Jahr übernommen hat. Auch wenn das Angebot Fehlversprechen klingt, empfehlen wir, AGBs lesen und kritisch bleiben. Wenn wie Opera den VPN-Dienst gegenfinanzieren will, scheint noch nicht klar. Die kanadische Polizei verfügt offenbar seit dem Jahr 2010 über die Fähigkeit, Nachrichten des Blackberry Messengers zu entschlüsseln. Dazu verwendeten sie den globalen Schlüssel, den eigentlich nur Blackberry besitzen sollte. Es ist daher anzunehmen, dass das Unternehmen den Schlüssel selber an die Behörden übergeben hat. Eigentlich sollten zentrale Schlüsseldankmethoden wie Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung jedoch gar nicht notwendig sein. Entsprechend schlecht schneidet der Blackberry Messenger auf dem Secure Messaging Scoreboard der Electronic Frontier Foundation ab. Dieses gibt eine Übersicht der Sicherheit von Messagern unter verschiedenen Sicherheitsaspekten. Den Link findet ihr in den Show Notes. Sicherheitsforscher von Checkpoint haben das sogenannte Nuclear Exploit Kit analysiert, mit dem Kriminelle vor allem den Verschlüsseln des Trojaner Loki verbreiten. Es bemüht dabei gleich mehrere Sicherheitslücken in VB und JavaScript für Internet Explorer sowie Flash und Microsoft Silverlight. Weitreichende Freiheiten bei der Gestaltung von Werbekampagnen sorgen immer wieder dafür, dass auch vermeintlich vertrauenswürdige Websites durch eingebundene Werbung zur Infektionsquelle werden können. Damit eure nicht dazu gehören, empfehlen sich wie immer regelmäßige Updates, einen guten Adblocker und einen Browser mit Click-to-Run-Funktion oder eine Mülltonne für untote Browser-Erweiterungen wie Silverlight, Java und Flash.
Und damit herzlich willkommen zurück zum Chaos Radio 222 aus der Marienstraße 11, wo es heute um Orte geht wie den Ort in der Marienstraße 11. Das ist nämlich die Heimat des Chaos Computer Club Berlins. Und es geht heute um Hackspaces oder Hackerspaces. Und wir haben schon in den ersten Stunden, in der ersten Stunde gelernt, was das überhaupt ist und was man braucht, um das zu gründen und haben auch etwas über dieses Design Pattern Handbook oder wie auch immer das genau hieß. Ich hab's schon wieder vergessen.
Hackerspace Design Patterns.
Hackerspace Design Patterns gelernt. Ich begrüße nochmal herzlich die Gäste. Gizmo ist das. Hallo und guten Abend. Ich verwechsel die beiden immer, sie sehen auch so ähnlich aus. Aber der eine hat eine Mütze und der mit der Mütze ist Joel. Und Pylon.
Hallo.
Und ihr wolltet noch kurz etwas zu den Design Patterns sagen.
Ja, das Spannende ist halt einfach bei den Design Patterns gewesen. Wir hatten halt den Vortrag dann in Köln gemacht, eine kleine Runde mit zehn US-Hackern halt zusammen. Und im Anschluss kam dann Brie Pettis auf mich zu, wie gerade schon angesprochen, bei dem Make-Magazin damals dabei gewesen, hat er geschrieben und fragte mich so, kann ich die Folien haben? Ich sagte, ja klar, hier hast du einen USB-Stick, kurz mal übergeben. Was ich nicht wusste, ist, dass er zwei Minuten später auf das Blog vom Make-Magazin gestellt hatte. Das Ding dann irgendwie einmal komplett weltweit rumgegangen ist, irgendwie zigtausend Leute erreicht hatte und plötzlich poppten dann irgendwie weltweit so die ganzen Hackerspaces auf. Es wurde in mehrere Sprachen übersetzt, es hat aber ungefähr fünf bis sechs Jahre gedauert, bis man in Deutsch übersetzt wurde. Aber es gab irgendwie ganz schnell danach dann irgendwie so spanische und japanische Übersetzungen, was ich total lustig fand. Und was auch noch interessant war, dass viele von den Pattern so eins zu eins übernommen wurden. Ein Beispiel wäre so ein Pattern mit reingebracht, so das Mate-Pattern. Also du brauchst in einem Hackspace Mate. Was man hier so auf dem Tisch stehen sieht, so damit man auch nicht einschläft, ist auch besser als diese komischen andere zuckerhaltige Getränke mit Koffein. Also hab Mate da. Da gab's dann auf einmal plötzlich so ganze Vertriebskanäle, die dann irgendwie versucht haben, Mate in alle Welt zu importieren quasi. Es ist grauenhaft, wo du heutzutage überall Mate findest. Du kannst wirklich in fast jeden Space reinkommen, egal wo du hingehst, ob du jetzt irgendwie in USA bist, in der Türkei bist oder sonst wo auch immer. Du findest Mate dort vor Ort.
Dann hast du ja auch klar geworden, was ihr damit angerichtet habt.
Eine weltweite Bewegung.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich so. Es gibt dieses Verzeichnis hackerspaces.org, das ist ein Wiki und da werden halt die ganzen Digger gesammelt, da findet man auch die Design-Patterns. Und 2007 war halt so ein Explosionsjahr, da ist halt irgendwie von ein paar Spaces, die da verzeichnet werden, ist es dann ganz schnell in eine dreistellige und dann vierstellige Zahl irgendwie von Spaces gekommen.
Also liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, passt auf, was ihr aufschreibt, es könnte möglicherweise ein weltweiter Trend daraus werden.
Ja, tatsächlich bin ich auch ein bisschen stolz. Also dieses Wort hackerspaces, wo ich immer noch nicht genau weiß, von wem das eigentlich geprägt ist.
Publikum, weiß das jemand?
War halt einfach da so 2006 rum und ja, ein paar Jahre später, also ich glaube vor ein paar Jahren, hat dann halt auch das Oxford English Dictionary beschlossen, das dann halt aufzunehmen.
Ach wirklich?
Und das passiert einem ja auch nicht so oft im Leben, dass halt so ein Wort, wo man die Bewegung halt mit initiiert hat, dass das dann halt irgendwie in so einem Wetterbuch auftaucht.
Meine Herren, liebes Internet, falls du weißt, wo das hackerspaces herkommt, auch gerne sagen, bei Twitter, at chaosradio oder...
Am Anfang auch so. Es klingt auf jeden Fall sehr germanisch. Hackerspace und so, das klingt wie so eine Kompositionsbildung, die halt so Deutschen gefällt. Deswegen glaube ich, dass es halt schon so aus unseren Kreisen kommt, um das zu beschreiben, was wir halt machen. Manchen Leuten, ja gerade wenn man dann hackerspace sagt, dann klingt das im Deutschen so, als ob da halt nur männliche Hacker sind und die Hackerinnen irgendwie draußen bleiben. Deswegen benutzen manche das Wort hackspaces. Aber eigentlich ist es egal. Also benutzt einfach das Wort, was euch lieber ist und ob ihr hackspace oder hackerspace sagt. In den USA gibt es auch ein Female-only-hackerspace. Macht einfach, was ihr für richtig haltet. Mich stört das nicht.
Ich wollte hier aber genau zu dem Punkt zurückkommen, den wir vor der Musik hatten. Und zwar, dass es dieses Leute treffen zusammen, gründen zusammen etwas und brauchen dann naja ein Konzept dafür, wie man Entscheidungen trifft. Und ich bin darauf gekommen, weil ich mal ganz fasziniert dabei war, wie ein Hausprojekt angefangen wurde. Und da wurde als allererstes, also bevor alles andere probiert wurde, wurde sozusagen, wurde ich zusammengesetzt und tatsächlich aufgeschrieben, wie die Entscheidungsfindung in der Gruppe so auszusehen hat. Das fand ich sehr, sehr, sehr spannend. Jetzt ist es ja so, die hackspaces, das habe ich heute gelernt, sind eher so Dinge, die relativ spontan passieren und dann auch aus sich raus wachsen. Deswegen würde mich tatsächlich interessieren, wie sich das auch, vielleicht habt ihr auch Anekdoten sozusagen über den Lauf der Zeit entwickelt hat. Und Gizmo, ich würde gerne bei dir anfangen, weil du bist ja der Schuldige sozusagen, also der, der sich bei euch in der Raumfahrtagentur sozusagen hat hinstellen lassen, um eine Firma zu gründen. Bist du denn auch der Chef?
Nee, nicht wirklich. Wie gesagt, das organisatorische Vehicle hier ist die Firma, die eben dann auch den Mietvertrag hält, die Stromrechnung bezahlt und eine Versicherung haben wir noch für ein paar Kleinigkeiten, das war's. Das wird getragen komplett von den Beiträgen. Das ist ungefähr so das, was zu null laufen muss, sonst wird es irgendwann schwierig. Das ist auch der Fall über die Jahre, sind jetzt acht Jahre damit relativ gut rumgegangen. Wir haben zwei Umzüge hinter uns gebracht. Zur Entscheidung gehören natürlich schon auch noch ein paar mehr, vor allem die Leute, die diese Werkstatt nutzen und den Raum nutzen. In der Organisation von der Raumfahrtagentur ist es so, dass wir da jetzt nicht dedizierte Bereiche haben für Leute, die dort ihren Arbeitsplatz haben oder ihren Schreibtischspiel, so ein Co-Working-Space, sondern es gibt nur dedizierte Werkstattbereiche. Also die unterschiedlichen Maschinen, die unterschiedlichen Disziplinen, Techniken haben jeweils einen definierten Bereich, einen Teil des Raums zwischen eben 3D-Druck, Tonstudio, Textilverarbeitung, Elektrotechnik, solche Sachen. Und da bilden sich zwangsläufig Krüppchen drum rum, Nutzer, Kernuser, also Leute, die regelmäßig im Space sind, die mit einem Thema sehr vertraut sind, womöglich selber noch eine Maschine mitgebracht haben, die also da so ein bisschen den Hut aufhaben in diesem einzelnen Bereich. Und dann Leute außen rum, die das halt regelmäßig nutzen oder auch seltener, je nachdem. Und so ist es also, was mich betrifft, so den Chef zu spielen, eigentlich die initiale Claim-Geschichte zu handeln. Also wo welche Bereiche landen. Wenn es darum geht, einen neuen Raum, wie gesagt, zwei Umzüge waren es bisher, zu besiedeln, gilt. Danach halte ich mich da auch schwer zurück. Beziehungsweise danach ist es Gegenstand von den Leuten, die es betreiben und die diese Bereiche managen.
Aber geht das sozusagen immer konfliktfrei? Oder gibt es auch so Dinge, wo ja schon...
Gut, wie gesagt, das waren ja schon ein paar, ungefähr zehn Jahre Hintergrund. Die Leute verstehen sich ganz gut. Und gerade wenn es ums Fachliche geht, eben einen solchen Werkstattbereich, dann trifft man sich doch irgendwo in der Mitte und in dem Führung, dass es dann halt auch in Ordnung ist. Also sei das jetzt auch so ein bisschen eine Policy zum Aufräumen oder zum Bestandhalten. Das müssen dann die Leute im Unterricht klären. Sie machen einzeln jeder Fachbereich. Ich wollte gerade sagen, da gibt es auch so ein paar Unterschiede. Dass, ja, Östern-Tagesgeschehen ist klar, da ist natürlich auch immer wieder was los. Große Kernfragen nicht. Und auch der Investitionsbereich ist bei uns immer so ein bisschen außen vor. Das machen die Projekte, die Leute selber.
Herr Graf-Bürger, ich hätte dich nicht fragen sollen, wie trefft Entscheidungen, sondern wer putzt eigentlich? Aber gut. Joel, wie ist das bei dir? Entscheidungsstrukturen in Hackspaces. Wie macht man es am besten? Ich meine, klar, ihr habt in eure Design-Pattern geschrieben, irgendwie Dienstagsplanung. Aber funktioniert das denn immer und funktioniert das so reibungsfrei? Also wenn ihr mir jetzt, also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, wenn ihr mir jetzt alles erzählt, es gibt keine Probleme und das Plenum ist ein wunderbarer Ort und es regnet Blumen, dann muss ich sagen, dann habe ich die Menschheit bis jetzt falsch eingeschätzt oder ihr erzählt mir Märchen.
Nein, das ist kein Buckle, das ist kein Feature. Es gibt keinen Hackerspace ohne Hackerspace Drama. Und der Goldstandard für Hackerspace Drama ist für mich Noise Bridge in San Francisco. Also die performen einfach das am besten, am unterhaltsamsten auf ihrer Mailing-Liste, um ein Beispiel zu nennen, das liegt halt in einem eher alternativen Teil von San Francisco. Und irgendwann war da so eine Gruppe, die gesagt hat, hier, ihr habt doch so einen offenen Raum und ihr seid doch völlig frei in euren Gedanken und jeder kann da was machen und wer macht, hat Recht und so weiter. Ich würde diesen Raum gerne nutzen. Und dann wurde gesagt, ja klar, mach ruhig. Der nächste, der dann in den Raum kam, fand den Hackerspace verwandelt in einen Sektentempel. Räucherstäbchen waren da, der Guru stand vorne, eine Gruppe von Meditierenden saß im Raum und hörte gespannt zu. Und irgendwann wurde dann das auch auf der Mailingliste gesagt, also ja, jeder kann sich hier selber verwirklichen und wer macht, hat Recht. Aber das geht jetzt doch ein bisschen weit weg von unseren Kernkompetenzen. Vielleicht sollten...
Das ist so eine Art Sielenlöten.
Genau. Also kein Hackerspace ohne Hackerspace Drama. Und meistens sind es halt auch wirklich diese Themen wie wer macht sauber, wer putzt die Klos? Im anderen Hackerspace, dem mir sie am Herzen liegt, das MetaLab in Wien. Da waren sie immer sehr stolz darauf, dass sie alles im Konsens machen und nie Abstimmungen machen müssen. Und dieses hässliche mit der Demokratie, das die größte Minderheit, die kleinen Minderheiten alle unterdrückt und so. Bis sie dann halt, ja das ist eine Geschichte, die ist schon ein bisschen älter. Mittlerweile hat sich das in Europa auch anders entwickelt. Aber damals haben die Leute noch geraucht. Ihr erinnert euch vielleicht, da gab es Raucher. Und da kam dann der Winter und einige Leute haben im Hackerspace geraucht. Und andere fanden das unmöglich. Und da gab es das erste Mal eine Abstimmung im Meta-Lab, wie die jetzt mit dem Raucherproblem vorzugehen ist. Man hat das dann so gelöst, dass man ein kleines Kabuff eingerichtet hat, das sogenannte Gesundheitskammerl. Und im Gesundheitskammerl durfte geraucht werden. Mittlerweile ist der ganze Hackerspace aber auch rauchfrei. Also Kultur ist irgendwie weitergegangen. Aber ja, kein Hackerspace ohne Hackerspace-Drama gehört dazu.
Okay, Pülon, hast du da auch noch eine Anekdote vielleicht beizusteuern?
Bekannt sind auch Schreitherapien bei Plenums. Das kommt auch immer wieder mal vor, dass dann doch durchaus die Gespräche etwas ausarten und ein bisschen lauter werden. Ich fand es früher anstrengend. Mittlerweile sehe ich das durchaus als Kulturprogramm an. Man kann da auch sich mal zurücklehnen, einfach mal fünf Minuten warten, bis alle Meinungen ausgetauscht wurden in etwas größerer Lautstärke. Dann geht das auch schon wieder vorbei, dann kann man wieder in Ruhe weiterreden.
Aber sowohl man macht das mit Schreiterpätherapie als auch, dass wer macht, hat recht. Das klingt aber schon noch, als die Leute, die viel Energie haben, bestimmen das Vorgehen im Hackerspace.
Ja, wenn wir jetzt weniger lustig darüber reden, es kann dazu führen, dass so ein Hackerspace umkippt, dass die Stimmung ganz schlecht wird und dass alles ein bisschen autoritärer wird. Das ist schlecht. Also wenn da irgendwie das Ganze innerlich vergammelt und eine schlechte Kultur drin ist, dann kann so ein Hackerspace auch umkippen.
Also warum ich mir die Frage stelle, ist, dass ich mir vorstellen könnte, dass es zum Problem werden kann im Sinne von, das wirkt ja, so wie es erzählt hat am Anfang, immer so relativ fluffig. Also man trifft sich so, man denkt so, hey, wir sind uns irgendwie sympathisch und wir gründen jetzt einfach mal dieses Ding und dann geht das vielleicht auch ganz lange im Konsens, dass man alles macht. Aber irgendwann erreicht das ja so eine kritische Schwelle, wo man merkt, jetzt geht es halt nicht mehr, jetzt können wir es sozusagen nicht einfach so machen, sondern jetzt müssen wir tatsächlich auch reflektieren und mal sozusagen darüber reden, wie wir vielleicht auch reden. Und ist das so eine Schwelle, woran so ein Hackerspace dann auch irgendwie zerbrechen oder scheitern kann? Wenn das nicht funktioniert?
Kann passieren. Also unsere Erfahrung sagt so aus den letzten 15, 20 Jahren, man hat immer so Höhen und Tiefen eines Spaces, man fließt ja in eine Sinuskurve oder so ein bisschen ansteigende Sinuskurve, die halt immer so ein bisschen mehr wird. Das heißt, man hat dann irgendwie mal so einen Hoch, vielleicht nach einem Camp, was halt alle vier Jahre stattfindet, dann ist es auf einmal super toll und der Space läuft super. Alle sind glücklich und es wird dann vorangearbeitet. Und irgendwann ist das für manche Leute vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel. Dann zertrennt sich so ein bisschen die Gruppe, schreit sich vielleicht mal zwischendurch auch an oder auch nicht. Und dann kann es passieren, dass die Gruppe auch mal zerbricht oder manche Leute in einen anderen Space gehen. Ich meine, es gibt Städte, wo mehrere Spaces sind. Dann besucht man einen anderen Space, geht mal ein bisschen Oper hacken und so was in der Richtung und kommt vielleicht später wieder. Aber man kann sagen, so eine Sinus-Kurve von fast schon vier Jahren, die man halt so dazwischen hat, so alle vier Jahre ist alles super. Und dann gibt es vielleicht immer zwei Jahre, wo es mal ein bisschen nicht so toll ist.
Das Camp ist an allem schuld.
Durchaus.
Cat, ich würde das von dich natürlich jetzt auch gerne fragen. Die eine Sache ist ja genau so sagen, man kann es halt sagen, wenn man jetzt so ein Ding gründet und das auch gleich in größer angeht, was ihr jetzt vorhat. Spielt das auch eine Rolle? Also habt ihr das auch vorher besprochen oder ergibt sich das auch so?
Also wir haben keine Entscheidungsstrukturen festgelegt, aber viele von uns haben so einen Aktivisten-Background irgendwie und auch teilweise in gemeinsamen Gruppen, wo wir auch so Pläne haben und Basisdemokratie, die schon sehr lange sehr gut funktioniert. Und würden das denke ich auch auf diesen Space anwenden. Und da wird auch nicht so oft rumgeschrieben.
Aber was heißt das konkret?
Dass Entscheidungen einfach im Plenum getroffen werden, aber nicht mit Mehrheiten, sondern so weit das Möglichkeit ist, jeder seine Meinung preisgeben kann und dann gemeinsam eine Lösung findet.
Das klingt alles so schön.
Es kann auch funktionieren.
Also es ist auch nur fast unrealistisch, weil die Leute, die so ein Hackerspace bevölkern, die sind halt ganz stark intrinsisch motiviert. Die wollen halt einen eigenen Raum haben. Die haben Wissensdurst und die brennen innerlich dafür, dass dieser Raum gefüllt wird. Da ist ganz selten die Motivation, ich mach jetzt alles kaputt. Trotz aller Schreittherapie und so findet man doch dann wieder zueinander.
Meine Vermutung war tatsächlich auch nicht gewesen, dass jemand denkt, ich mach jetzt alles kaputt, sondern dass es zwei Leute geben, die eine ganz genaue oder zwei Lager gibt, oder drei oder vier, die eine ganz genaue Vorstellung davon haben, was der richtige Weg TM ist, um sozusagen den Hackerspace zu betreiben. Aber ihr habt vorhin vieles, das war ein Halbsatz, und da würde ich gerne nochmal genauer hingucken, die Tür. Ich kann mir vorstellen, es gibt tatsächlich bei Hackerspaces viele praktische Probleme, die man irgendwie klären muss. Zum Beispiel, wie dick ist eigentlich die Internetanbindung, die man in so einem Hackerspace braucht. Reicht eine landesübliche 100-VDSL-Leitung, falls man die Verfügung hat, oder braucht man mehr? Da wird der Fuel schüttelt mit dem Kopf, sagt man, eine Zahl einfach nur?
Ja, immer das Maximum, was geht. Also Glasfaser direkt in den Hackerspace.
Okay, und dann ist es tatsächlich die Frage der Tür. Das ist ja eigentlich ganz spannend. Weil man wird ja wahrscheinlich keinen da haben, der auf die Tür aufpasst. Das heißt, man muss entscheiden, wer darf denn da ein- und ausgehen.
Genau, da gibt es unterschiedliche Modelle, also auch in den meisten Spaces, die ich so kenne, ist das so, dass irgendwie den Schlüsselmember zu sein, das hat irgendwie dann was mit Mitgliedschaft in dem Hackerspace zu tun. Und ist dann oft auch an bestimmte Sachen gebunden, dass man dann halt irgendwie regelmäßig auf dem Plenum erscheint oder in dem Entscheidungsgremium, was es da gibt. Das ist dann meistens noch so eine nicht so thematisierte Hierarchie, die dir nachher reingegeben wird. Das sind die Mitglieder und das sind die Mitglieder mit Schlüssel. Es gibt allerdings auch ganz andere. Also NoiseBridge, die ich eben als Goldstandard in Drama erwähnt habe. Die sind halt aber auch in anderen Sachen richtig goldig und lieb. Also Mitch Altman von NoiseBridge fährt durch die Welt und verteilt Schlüssel für den NoiseBridge Hackerspace. Ich hab dann auch einen bekommen. Du hast bestimmt auch einen.
Ich hab einen aber nie benutzt, weil ich noch nie da war.
Genau, also einfach, wenn ihm Leute sympathisch sind, drückt er einem den Schlüssel in die Hand. Das ist halt eine maximal offene Türpolitik, weil das halt auch immer alles gerne technisch gelöst wird. Wollte ich gerade fragen. Gibt's halt irgendwie ganz unterschiedliche Lösungen. Fast jeder Hackerspace fängt dann erst mal mit einem Türprojekt an. Also wir müssen erstmal an den Türstatus nach außen kommunizieren. Irgendwie ein Bot, der das auf Twitter macht oder auf der Webseite wird ein grünes Lämpchen angeschaltet oder sowas. Das ist so ein Standardprojekt, was irgendwie jeder Hackerspace am Anfang machen soll. Mittlerweile gibt es, weil wir ja alle Standards lieben, halt auch einen Hackerspace-Türstatus-Standard. Da gibt es halt eine API-Spezifikation, wie man halt in Hackerspaces auf der Welt den jeweiligen Status dann abfragen kann.
Aber warte, meine Theorie wäre, es gibt zwar diese API, aber es hat noch kein Hackerspace geschafft, die umzusetzen.
Nee, das haben erstaunlich viele Hackerspaces.
Ich möchte mal, können wir bitte kurz aufzeigen, wer ist denn alles aus dem Marienstraße 11, also den Ort, an dem wir uns befinden hier? Aha, hier geht nur eine Hand hoch. Ach, da hinten noch ein paar. Gibt es hier ein Türprojekt? Weiß das jemand?
Nee, nicht wirklich. Das hier ist ganz klassisch. Hier gibt es Schlüssel tatsächlich. Und du musst schon dazugehören und dass sie entsprechende Vertrauen auch aufgebaut haben in der Halberg-Gruppe, um dir einen Schlüssel ergattern zu dürfen.
Das Vertrauen, wie macht man das? Weil Schlüsselmämmer viele ja schon sagen, so eine Hierarchie gibt es ja auch im Designpattern. Oder gibt es da auch sozusagen...
Das war nicht damals im Designpattern vorgesehen. Wir haben ganz viel übersehen, was wir dann halt irgendwie...
Aber gibt es in euren Erlebnissen jetzt sozusagen, was muss ein... Also eine Raumfahrt Agentur ist wahrscheinlich zu sagen, wenn man da an sich den Werkstatt, sozusagen wenn der Werkstatt nachher darf, dann geht das?
Ganz klassisch, es gibt auch eine Schließanlage, Schlüsselsystem, also entsprechend, genau, also Schlüsselmember, keine elektronische Anzeige über den Besatzungsstatus.
Aber was muss man machen, um Schlüsselmember zu werden? Also wie...
Selbes Spiel, es ist eine Vertrauensfrage natürlich, Zugang zu den Räumen zu gewähren und dementsprechend sind das bekannte Leute, die schon länger da sind, das wachsen Leute mit in der Raumfahrt Agentur dazu. Also die freuen jetzt nicht unbedingt direkt aus dem CCC-Umfeld, die schon bekannt waren. Das ist dann natürlich so eine Übergangsphase und man lernt sich erstmal kennen und dann tauchen die regelmäßiger auf, man kommt da so ein bisschen weiter rein. Und dann ist das dann auch irgendwann geklärt. Beziehungsweise dann ist dann auch die Schlüsselfrage.
Kat, habt ihr da schon irgendwie Pläne? Wollt ihr das... Also gibt's schon einen Plan?
Also wir haben in unseren Finanzplan 20 Schlüssel reingeschrieben. Wir haben irgendwie ein Budgetverschlüssel, aber wir haben da noch keinen Plan. Ich glaube, es kommt auch ein bisschen drauf an, wo der Space ist, wenn einer von uns direkt nebenan wohnt und die Tür aufmacht. Also keine Ahnung, müssen wir mal sehen.
Aber ihr habt auch nicht geplant, dass es irgendwie Öffnungszeiten gibt oder so was?
Also soll halt möglichst offen sein, die meiste Zeit einfach.
Wie ist es bei euch zu sagen, wie wird man Schlüsselmember? Wenn jetzt nicht gerade jemand von der Neuspitch kommt und sagt, hier, geiler Typ, du hast einen Schlüssel.
Naja, wenn du jetzt nicht selbst den Space mit gegründet hast und dann quasi zu der Ursuppe dazu gehörst, dann hilft es schon, einfach mal vorbei zu kommen an einem offenen Tag. Zum Beispiel Dienstag, wenn er offen ist. Dich einfach einzubringen, vorzustellen, ins Gespräch zu kommen. Öfters wiederzukommen, einfach mal regelmäßig da zu sein. Ob es jetzt einmal im Monat ist oder wöchentlich. Ein bisschen was Vertrauen aufzubauen. Vielleicht auch mal einen Vortrag reinzubringen oder einen Workshop. Dann irgendwann so, du bist ja so oft hier und du hast ja schon mal mitgekauft, Toilette zu putzen.
Möchtest du Schlüssel haben? Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, das ist der wichtige Punkt. Ihr müsst einmal die Toilette mitgeputzt haben. Gut, was man sonst noch so in Hackerspace machen kann, also ab von denen das alleine runterwerkelt, das klären wir gleich. Jetzt noch eine kleine Musik von Ryan Harley, Growing Pain. Growing Pains von Ryan Harley hier im Chaosradio 222, wo wir noch eine halbe Stunde haben, um über Hackspaces zu reden. Und wir wissen jetzt eigentlich schon alles, was man braucht, um sie zu gründen. Also wichtig ist, dass man einen Verein hat, dass man Geld hat, dass man eine Tür mit Schlüsseln hat und dass man das Klo putzt. Das ist jetzt so ganz grob zusammengefasst die letzten 90 Minuten.
Das ist aber schon sehr grob.
Ja, naja, man kann ja, man soll ja auch sozusagen den Podcast nochmal hören können, wenn er dann raus ist. Die sind auch mittlerweile schon Gäste abhanden gekommen. Ach ja, guck mal, da kommt der Pylon nochmal zurück. Wo sind eigentlich die Ketten? Verschwunden, explodiert.
Wir überzeugen uns von dem Ort der vorbildlichen Sauberkeit und Ordnung in diesen Räumen.
Wir möchten das nicht weiter ausfinden und ins Detail sagen. Jetzt ist es ja so, der Hackspace, über den wir jetzt geredet haben, ist ja ein Ort, in dem sie Individuen finden und dort sozusagen ihr individuelles Zeug machen. Jetzt sind wir alle Individuen, aber wenn Menschen zusammenkommen, kann es vielleicht noch ein bisschen weitergehen. Gibt es das tatsächlich, also gibt es außerdem Plenum noch andere Dinge, die man zusammen macht? Also jetzt, okay, man ist vielleicht zu dritt an der Werkbahn, weil man ein gemeinsames Projekt hat oder sowas. Bei Cat klang es vorhin schon an, also, nee andersrum, du hast ja erzählt, das hat sich daraus entwickelt. Ihr habt ganz viele Angebote für Frauen gemacht, die total überlaufen sind. Wie ist jetzt dieser Hackspace gedacht? Ist da auch dieses Gemeinschaftsding, soll das da mit drin vorkommen?
Ja absolut, also alles was da entsteht, entsteht ja aus einer Gemeinschaft heraus und es geht ja auch viel darum, irgendwie mehr Frauen in diese Community mit rein zu holen und das funktioniert unter anderem dadurch, dass man auch zum Beispiel Einsteiger-Workshops anbietet. Ja, dann sind überhaupt erstmal die Leute irgendwie da abgeholt, wo sie sind. Also das machen wir und ganz viele von den Workshops, die wir jetzt anbieten, die entstehen einfach auch aus der Community heraus, dass die Frauen sagen irgendwie so, ja, ich hab Bock, einen Hardware-Workshop anzubieten, ich bring euch Löten bei oder so, das passiert da so.
Aber ist das sozusagen so, jemand kommt und sagt, ich mach das einfach und dann versammeln sie sich um einen Tisch, der gerade da ist, irgendwie vier Leute oder wird das wirklich so geplant? Also am 23.08. um 17 Uhr Workshop, Löten, Platzzahl, 30 Leute.
Genau, das wird schon so geplant. Also wir haben ja jetzt noch keinen Space, wo man sich irgendwie versammeln kann, außer Donnerstags. Donnerstags wollen wir auch irgendwie ein Kulturprogramm anbieten. Das wird aber alles mal vorher angekündigt. Und bei den Workshops ist es in der Regel so, man sagt, ich bock das zu machen irgendwie. Dann müssen wir gucken, wo wir einen Raum herkriegen. Also wir haben ja wie gesagt viele Organisationen, die uns unterstützen, deren Büros wir nutzen können oder Labs. Und dann kündigen wir das im Kanäler an oder auf Twitter, mit einem Twitter-Account. Genau, und dann wenn es eine begrenzte Platzanzahl gibt, das meistens leider so ist, weil man die Leute ja betreuen muss, je nachdem, was man da macht, dann müssen die sich anmelden.
Wie ist das in der Raumfahrt Agentur? Das ist ja sozusagen ein eher geschlossener Verein. Du hast erzählt, ihr habt verschiedene in dem Space Spaces, wo das einzelne Werkzeug sozusagen ist, worum sich Gruppenbildung, aber habt ihr auch Dinge, die ihr alle zusammen macht oder ist das wirklich eher so eine Art zusammengestecktes Modul, wo sich kleine Gruppen haben?
Ja, das ist schon sehr zusammengesteckt. Gemeinschaftswerkstatt, die Räume sind physisch die Klammer, wo wir da operieren. Und wir sind in dem Fall sehr verteilt, unterschiedlichste Projekte, unterschiedlichste Leute. Da sind dann die für sich selbst zuständig, einen öffentlichen Auftritt zu machen, das zu kommunizieren. Wir laden dann auch gerne mal ein, lange Jahre BioLab mit im Haus gehabt von einer Dame, die dort DIY-Bio-Technik betrieben hat. Da finden dann natürlich auch mal Veranstaltungen oder Talks statt, solche Sachen. Aber das ist dann schon immer sehr konzentriert auf die Projekte, die dort halt ansässig sind. Elektronenrad, wenn ich jetzt hier mit meinen Elektrofahrrädern ein Thema habe und so, dann ist klar, Raumfahrtagentur ist die Raum, die Möglichkeit in der Werkstatt, wo sowas passiert, aber einen großen Auftritt und eine Präsentation, wie es beim Hard of Code sein wird, ist das gar nicht da an der Stelle.
Okay, also während man sich so zu sagen Hard of Code zum Beispiel, als das eine große Theater vorstellen kann, seid ihr eher das Kino mit verschiedenen Sälen? Pylon & Joel, wie ist es bei euch sozusagen, also Dinge, die Hackerspaces für die Gemeinschaft bringen? Was kann da noch passieren?
Das ist ganz unterschiedlich. In Köln läuft immer noch regelmäßig ein an einem Jahr mehrwöchiges Projekt für Jugendliche, das ist so genannte U23, also für Leute unter 23, dass dort dann eine Projektreihe ist, die sich bestimmten Themen widmet, sei es Software, sei es Hardware, also irgendwo dran rumhacken. Was dann ja reingebracht wird mit einem bestimmten Ziel, dass am Schluss das Ganze präsentiert wird. Das läuft dann so über zwei Monate. Da wirken auch sehr viele von dem Club dann selbst auch mit. Was noch gibt, sind halt Vorträge. Das ist auch hier in Berlin halt regelmäßig, dass es einmal im Monat den Vortrag hier gibt, den Club Discord ja, Quatsch, den Datengarten heißt das hier, so rum. Genau, richtig. Und das dann Vortrag zum offenen Thema ist, was dann hier live angeschaut werden kann oder auch gestreamt wird, aufgenommen wird, verbreitet wird. Das sind so einzelne Projekte oder was hier jetzt auch stattgefunden hat, um mal kurz da reinzugehen. Ich hatte jetzt zum Beispiel einen Amateurfunklehrgang gemacht hier in den Clubräumen, bietet sich an, ist halt groß, hier gibt es eine Leinwand, kann man halt einfach vorstellen, das ganze Leute halt zum Amateurfunk zu bringen, woraus sich dann auch nochmal eine komplett eigene Gruppe entwickelt hat, die sich weiterhin hier regelmäßig trifft.
Ist das generell was, wo man sagen kann, dafür sind Hackspaces auch geeignet. Ich bin jemand, der, wenn man sich durchguckt, also Hackspace irgendwie das Thema, das dazu passt, aber ich bin jemand, der gerne etwas anbieten würde. Selbst wenn ich nicht dazugehöre, gehe ich hin und frage mal, wie wär's denn, könnte ich bei euch, also so wie es Hard of Code jetzt anscheinend bis jetzt schonmal einer gemacht hat, ist das so ein Ding, was eher typisch ist auch für Hackspaces?
Ja, würde ich auch so sagen. Also wir hatten vor ein paar Monaten mal eine Anhörung im Landtag Nordrhein-Westfalen, wo es darum ging, die Politiker wollten sich mal erklären lassen, was das eigentlich mit diesen Hackerspaces auf sich hat und ob man da irgendwie das Modell der Kulturförderung drauf anwenden kann und so. Und also in Nordrhein-Westfalen ist die FDP noch im Landtag und ein Abgeordneter von der FDP meinte dann, also wenn ich sie jetzt richtig verstanden habe, betreiben sie so eine Art anarchistische Volkshochschule. Das trifft das eigentlich ganz gut. Also so neue Formen des Voneinander-Lernens werden auf jeden Fall ausprobiert und das kann halt ganz ad hoc sein, dass man einfach jemanden über die Schulter guckt, der sein Ding macht oder manche sagen halt, wir machen jetzt auch mal eine Kursreihe, wir machen eine Vortragsreihe. Das gehört auch dazu, dass man halt eine eigene Form des Lernens ausprobiert.
Jetzt hast du gesagt, der Landtag hat mal gefragt, das stelle ich mir auch spannend vor, also auch hier wieder, der ursprüngliche Ansatz ist, Individuen suchen im Prinzip eine Höhle, wo sie ungestört die Dinge tun können, die sie tun. Aber wenn das dann so eine Außenwirkung hat oder wenn Leute von Außen das mitbekommen, dann wirkt das vielleicht viel größer als organisatorische Einheit, als es vielleicht eigentlich gedacht ist. Gibt es so, gerade auch weil es in Berlin zum Beispiel so viele gibt, gibt es mittlerweile so eine Art Anspruch, der von außen immer beobachten kann, ich werde jetzt irgendwie als Entität wahrgenommen?
Ja, haben wir versucht, es war vor vier Jahren schon gewesen, da waren wir dann auch im Abgeordnetenhaus, haben dort auch mal Hackerspaces einfach mal vorgestellt, um mal reinzubringen, was ist das überhaupt, um das als Kultur für Berlin auch wahrzunehmen. Haben dort im Kultur-Aschauß auch mit dabei gesessen. Frank-Rieger und ich waren da halt drin, haben das Ganze vorgestellt. Letzten Endes ist es glaube ich irgendwie bei der SPD dort hängen geblieben, ach so, das ist also auch noch mal so ein Raum, wo sich Bands treffen können, um proben zu können. Die kennen das nicht anders hier in dieser Stadt. Das ist als Band-Proberaum, das kann man alles über den Band-Proberaum-Geldzuschuss finanzieren. Die haben es einfach nicht verstanden, leider.
Ja, aber es ist nicht so, dass dann auch Leute, was ich jetzt eigentlich mal so sagen kann, sagen, ihr seid doch so ein Hackerspace, könnt ihr nicht mal mein 3D-Klima-Lager auspucken?
Ein bisschen geht es schon weiter. Ich habe es in Köln gemerkt, mit der Dingfabrik. Das kam schon ganz anders als FabLab. Da ist dann hinter die Stadt auch mit draufgesprungen. Die haben das dann wahrgenommen und sehen das als Kultur. Teilt der Stadt auch mit an. Es kommt wirklich von Stadt zu Stadt auch drauf an, wie die Leute dort in den entsprechenden Gremien drin sitzen, ticken und verstehen, was so ein Hackerspace ist.
Kat, könnte ich mir vorstellen, ist das oder andersrum gefragt. Das hört sich jetzt so an, ihr wollt jetzt einen Hackerspace gründen, damit ihr einen Ort habt, an dem ihr mir die Dinge tun könnt, die ihr sowieso schon tut, nämlich Angebote für Frauen machen. Ist es aber gleichzeitig auch gedacht als eine Art politischer Leuchtturm, wo man genau dieses Thema, dieses Anliegen, das da besteht, nämlich Frauen in Zugang zu ermöglichen, dass es einen Kristallisationspunkt gibt, wo man sagen kann, wenn ich mich für das Thema interessiere, muss ich dahin gehen. Ist das auch Teil des Plans?
Ja, das ist natürlich auch Teil des Plans. Hauptsächlich wollten wir einfach einen Space haben, wo wir hacken können. Abnerden, aber das politische schwingt natürlich mit. Das ist ja auch ein total wichtiges Thema. Wir schaffen damit eine Sichtbarkeit für Frauen. Das ist auch ein wichtiges Anliegen und auch ein Aspekt der Hard-of-Code, den wir auf jeden Fall haben, zwecken.
Ich habe jetzt widersprüchliche Informationen in dieser Sendung bekommen. Das eine ist, dass irgendwann gesagt wurde, eigentlich in Berlin letzten Mal noch mal ein Hackspace aufzumachen. Schwierig, ist schon ganz schön voll. Gizmo hat aber gerade gesagt, mehr neue Hackspace. Das ist das Allerbeste, was uns passieren kann. Ich nehme da Mixed Signals wahr. Also sind jetzt genug in Berlin oder brauchen wir noch mehr?
Ich bin der Meinung, es kann immer gerne noch einen mehr geben. Und Hackerspaces an jeder Ecke kann auch nicht schaden in der Struktur. Ich habe die Erfahrung gemacht, dass gerade ein sehr lokaler Umkreis wichtig ist. Also dass so ein Hackspace nicht am anderen Ende der Stadt liegt. Gerade in Berlin, Finsteres, Neukölln, was jetzt für uns, für die Raumfahrt Agentur genau das andere Ende ist. Ist doch so eine schwierige Sache, wenn man da erst anreist und alle Pläne des regelmäßigen Erscheinens und umso fleißigeren Tüftelns gehen dann meistens doch irgendwie zurück, wenn das nicht doch ein bisschen ein lokales Wohnzimmer auch ist. Oder Arbeitszimmer eben.
Was heißt lokal? Ein Block oder ein Straßenzug?
Ja, was man mit dem Elektrofahrrad so in zehn Minuten schafft. Auf jeden Fall eine halbe Stunde Bahn und noch viel mehr, noch längere Wege sind ein anderes Kriterium. Das sind dann schon andere Situationen. Gerade für ihr Arbeiten und auch Freizeit.
Aber das ist schon ein bisschen widersprüchlich. Wenn man so denkt, Hackspace als Ort der Begegnung, das nimmt dann auch so ein bisschen ab. Sondern man bleibt halt irgendwie so in seinem Kies.
Ja, andererseits aber wir haben, wie gesagt, von der Fläche sind es 250 Quadratmeter und da lange nicht alles abgedeckt. Mehrfachliches ist immer möglich. Und gerade dafür müsste es dann vielleicht auch noch andere Räume geben, die in dem Bereich Maschinen oder andere technische Zugangsmöglichkeiten da sind. Also das noch ein bisschen diverser zu haben oder da auch mehr Breite zu haben, sollte kein Problem sein.
Aber für dich sozusagen wäre es durchaus wünschen wert, wenn es jetzt eine Fachrichtung gibt, die es bei euch noch nicht gibt, dass die nicht dann auch noch zu euch kommt, sondern sagt, das wäre schon auch cool, macht doch einfach euren eigenen Space.
Gerade wenn der Raum schon am Limit ist und das ist ja also was jetzt die Raumstruktur betrifft, die ist definiert, das sind die Bereiche soweit gesetzt, dann klar, man muss ja nicht immer alles noch unter einen Dach drunter.
Ich mag es ja, wenn nicht alles immer wachsen muss. Cat, wie sieht es eigentlich zu sagen, wenn es angenommen noch ein Frauen-only-Hackspace in Berlin, gute Idee oder nicht?
Ja, total gute Idee. Also von mir aus noch fünf. Also ich glaube, es gibt genug Frauen, die Bock drauf haben und dir das Angebot wahrnehmen würden.
Okay, und Pylor und Joel, mehr Hackspace gleich gute Idee immer?
Ja, mehr Diversität und auch mehr Discordianismus dazwischen. Und irgendwie hab ich das Gefühl, man kennt sich ja doch untereinander, dass man sich halt mal besuchen geht, mal schaut irgendwo, was läuft in anderen Spaces, vielleicht mal ein cooles Vortragsprogramm da gerade läuft und einfach mal vorbeischaut und irgendwie mal auch den Blick in den Tellerrand irgendwie wagen kann. Oder auch man sieht so, hey, in der Raumfahrt Agentur, die haben einfach einen geilen Laserkater da rumstehen. Eigentlich will ich das in meinem Space und in die Ecke auch, um nicht immer natürlich halbe Stadt fahren zu müssen. Und da mal so ein bisschen einfach mitzunehmen.
Ich will einen Laserkater haben, weil ich das Gefühl, das fällt ganz schön oft. Jetzt gibt es noch einen Punkt, wo ich mich frage, die so ein ganz bisschen erinnert, das ja, was erzählt, auch so eine Künstlerkollektive. Und da gab es ja auch mal das Konzept, gleich ein ganzes Künstlerhaus ist. Also nicht nur, dass das, wie heißt das, von der Stadtplanung her, ein dritter Ort ist, sondern dass man sagt, man könnte es doch eigentlich gleich größer machen. Wir haben unsere Werkstatt und oben drüber wohnen wir alle. Gibt es so eine Konzepte auch? Also dass man nicht nur sagt, wir arbeiten und feiern vielleicht zusammen, sondern tatsächlich, wir machen gleich so ein Hack-Haus? Ja, gibt's auch.
Also es gab Planungen dazu und es sind auch welche umgesetzt worden. In Essen gibt es ein Haus, was aus einem Umfeld des Unperfekthauses herausgefallen ist, die dann auch quasi im Untergeschoss Ladengeräume haben, Werkstätten, damit man das Fahrrad nicht da oben schleppen muss zum Beispiel und oben drüber auch Wohnungen haben und als Kollektiv auch wahrgenommen wird.
Und wird sich das sozusagen, also ist das was, was vielleicht noch mehr jetzt kommt oder sind das so vereinzelte Dinge, die man mal macht?
Ich hab nicht so viele erfolgreiche Sachen gesehen in dem Bereich, was erstaunlich ist, weil das wirklich schon lange diskutiert wird. Also ich kann mir vorstellen, dass viele Leute dann auch sagen gut so ein Hackerspace mit dem inherenten Hackerspace-Drama will ich dann vielleicht nicht noch in meinem Privatleben haben.
Also was ich da noch fragen wollte, ist eigentlich, ist eure Erfahrung nach, ist Mailinglist ein diskutables Organisationsmittel für einen Hackerspace? Oder gibt es ja mittlerweile moderneres?
Ja, selten. Also das ist auf jeden Fall irgendwie das Grundmittel. Ist auch so ein bisschen, was wir auch in den Designpages mit aufgeschrieben haben. Also eine Mailingliste brauchst du schon. Mail kann irgendwie fast jede Person halt bearbeiten. Alles andere drüber hinaus ist ein Streitthema.
Ja, also Mailinglisten haben Probleme. Mailinglisten können total entgleisen. Irgendwann werden wir sicherlich auch was besseres als Mailinglisten haben, aber bis jetzt haben wir halt Mailinglisten. In den Designpattern haben wir gesagt, ihr braucht eine Mailingliste, um was zu diskutieren. Die Designpattern sind allerdings auch schon neun Jahre alt. Das war eine andere Zeit. Damals kannten wir auch kein Crowdfunding, das hieß damals noch Betteln. Jetzt sind wir alle ein bisschen weiter. Also damals haben wir gesagt, wir brauchen eine Mailingliste, ihr braucht einen Wiki, um Sachen aufzuschreiben, damit man die dann nachschlagen kann, also als Knowledge Base. Ihr braucht irgendwie ein Echtzeitmedium und das war damals IRC. Aus diesen drei Elementen könnt ihr euch dann eure sinnvolle Kommunikation zusammen basteln.
Ja, wir haben die Designpattern sehr nicht gelesen. Wir benutzen einfach Slack, das vereint die Funktionen alle ganz gut.
Da könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass es unter Hardcore-Open-Source-Leuten natürlich wieder eine riesige Diskussion darum geben kann.
Die Hardcore-Open-Source-Leute sollen bitte ein Tool bauen, das so funktioniert, wie Slack und Open Source ist. Da würde ich mich total freuen.
Falls jemand da was hat, gerne Bescheid sagen in den Kommentaren zur Sendung. Ich würde jetzt ganz zum Schluss noch mal ein bisschen nach eurem Nähkästchen fragen. Es gibt jetzt ganz viel, was wir gehört haben, wie man selber so einen Hackspace macht. Was man dafür braucht auch. Aber noch mal, wenn man jetzt auch denkt, ich würde mal rumreisen und mir vielleicht so ein paar angucken, in welche Städte lohnt es sich denn zu fahren? Oder was sind eure Lieblingshackspaces oder Geschichten, die ihr da erlebt habt oder Dinge, wo ihr sagt, okay, den muss man unbedingt mal gesehen haben. Das ist so ein Hackspace, den man auf jeden Fall nicht verpasst haben sollte. Also Berlin ist jetzt, können wir mal hier anfangen, es gibt hier die Marienstraße 11, Chaos Computer Club Berlin, da wird alle zwei Monate das Chaos Radio rausgesendet, da kann man sich den auch mal angucken. Gibt es hier auch offene Tage, wo man vorbeikommen kann, oder?
Dienstag und Donnerstag.
Dienstag und Donnerstag. Uhrzeit?
So abends ab 19.30, 20 Uhr so die Ecke rum.
Dann jetzt einmal rum vielleicht erstmal, wer noch mehr Geschichten hat, gerne auch die Hackspace, den man unbedingt gesehen haben sollte. Nicht der eigene Gizmo, nicht der eigene.
Okay, dann das Lobbo 23 in Würzburg.
Warum das?
Keinem Tipp.
Muss ja nicht immer die größten Städte sein.
War das dein erster?
Ja genau, das war historisch. Seit 2004 gibt es die da schon. Das ist da gewachsen. Ein ganz kleines Städtchen.
Ich war sehr beeindruckt in Oslo, also nicht vom BitRaf, das ist so der Hackerspace da, sondern da gibt es noch einen anderen Fabrikan, Fabrikan oder so heißt das. Das ist einfach ein wahnsinniger Makerspace. Das ist in einer riesigen Halle. Also die können in dieser Halle Hausboote bauen, so groß ist die und die haben halt total viele verschiedene Ecken. Die haben so eine riesige Textil-Ecke und die haben zwei so fette, krasse, dreimal zwei Meter Fräsen. Und die haben ganz viel Woodworking, also Holzkram. Und die haben so einen Roboterarm aus den 90ern und versuchen da gerade irgendwie eine Mischung aus 3D-Drucker und Fräse an diesen Roboterarm ranzubauen. Und die machen, also die sind richtig krasse Erfinder und die machen so geilen Scheiß. Und das war wirklich ziemlich beeindruckend. Das war glaube ich der coolste Space, in dem ich hier war.
Kannst du jemanden, der eh da war oder wie kommt man an sowas ran und rein?
Ja, der Typ, der das gegründet hat, da bin ich auch hier über den CTC quasi, über irgendwie so Hacker-Dings. Ich war in Oslo irgendwie und ich hatte keinen Bock im Hotel zu schlafen. Und dann habe ich einfach bei Freunden von Freunden geschlafen. Das war halt der Typ, der das gemacht hat. Und das war ein sehr schönes Wochenende.
Bester Hacker-Space aller Zeiten?
Wenn ich irgendwo hinfahre, dann besuche ich immer gerne Hacker-Spaces dort. Also in Helsinki war ich neulich und habe dort ein Hacker-Space gesehen. Total nett und kuschig und klein. Ich glaube, der, der mich am meisten beeindruckt hat, außer den erwähnten amerikanischen Spaces, NYC Resista in New York und Neuss Bridge in San Francisco, die muss man auch mal gesehen haben. Total toll. Ja, MetaLab in Wien ist auch auf jeden Fall irgendwie ganz, ganz wichtig zu erleben. Der mich am meisten beeindruckt hat, das war der Hacker-Space Singapur. Da war ich eingeladen worden von Umwege. Jemand, der auch auf dem CCC schon gesprochen hat, Joe Ito, hatte da was organisiert mit der Regierung von Singapur zusammen. Und da sollte ich dann was über Hackerspaces erzählen. Hab ich dann auch gemacht und hab denen auch was über Clubmarte erzählt. War nicht einfach rüber zu bringen. Dann wurde ich dann halt in diesen Hackerspace in Singapur eingeladen. Es war halt Dezember, es war 40 Grad draußen, richtig heiß. Und die hatten halt in dieser Stadt, die halt sowieso schon sehr interessant ist, also halt dieses Disneyland-Methode-Strafe, hat William Gibson das mal genannt, ganz interessante Kultur mit auf die Straße spucken, gibt vielleicht so und so viel Stockhiebe und so weiter. Da hatten sie sich dann so ihr anarchistisches Hackerspace-Refugium gebaut, wo sie halt auch irgendwie Schilder aufgestellt haben mit, wer pups zahlt so und so viel Singapur-Dollar und so. Und natürlich war das alles komplett anders. Also es ist halt irgendwie Asien und das ist halt in dem Viertel, was arabisch geprägt ist in Singapur. Und exotischer geht's nicht. Und ich hab die Tür aufgemacht und das war genauso wie zu Hause. Also es war, da waren halt meine Leute da. Und das Einzige, was vielleicht noch irgendwie anders war, dass die halt aus dem Hackerspace Singapur mich dann gefragt haben, und du bist aus dem Hackerspace in Deutschland.
Pilar? Ja, es lohnt sich auf jeden Fall, wenn man unterwegs ist, mal Urlaub gemacht und irgendwie mal so nach einer Woche rumreisen und irgendwelche Landschaft anguckt, mal wieder ein bisschen Kultur, also die Hackkultur erleben möchte. Mal einen Blick auf die Hackerspace-Karte zu werfen und zu schauen, ist irgendwie in meiner Gegend mal so ein Hackerspace. Ich hab das da mal vor ein paar Jahren gemacht, dass ich in New York in Nordendland unterwegs war. Und die hatten zufährweise Club-Abend an dem Abend, wo ich dann in der Stadt war, bin einfach mal vorbei gegangen. Das war irgendwie so typisch britisches Clubhaus. Das heißt, sie haben da so Häuser, wo sich mehrere Gruppen drin treffen. Man zahlt dann irgendwie so seine Zweifel und Eintritt und darf dann auch noch hinter an die Theke gehen. Die hatten dann so einen Raum hinten, wo sich dann dieser lokale Hackerspace getroffen hatte. Die dann auch irgendwie in den Schrank kamen, wo sie Zeugs einlagern können. Die treffen sich einmal die Woche halt dort. Irgendwie waren da gerade ein paar Leute einfach da gewesen, die dann einen alten Amiga auseinandergeschraubt haben. Da dachten wir so, ja, hier bist du schon irgendwie richtig. Es lohnt sich auf jeden Fall tatsächlich mal, in irgendwelche Räume reinzuschauen. Welcher Space mich jetzt vor Kurzem echt fasziniert hatte, wo ich vor einem Monat, Anfang des Monats war, in Augsburg gewesen, die sich vor ein, zwei Jahren da einen recht großen Space geleistet haben. Der ist auch komplett ausgestattet mit den ganzen Maschinenzeugen und mit Türöffnungsanlage, sonst wie auch immer. Das war echt faszinierend, diesen Raum zu sehen, wie die sich eingerichtet haben, weil er relativ frisch war, mit modernen Sachen, indirekte LED-Beleuchtung und so ein Kram, und gucken, dass man wenig Energie verbraucht. Da schon sehr viel Hackvalue reingesetzt haben.
Jetzt, weil Cat gerade gesagt hatte, Roboter-Arm mit 3D-Drucker und Frise dran. Krasseste Erfindung in einem Hackspace, die ich jemals gesehen hab? Oder krassestes Ding? Na, da werden die Köpfe bedächtig gewegt.
Ich hab ziemlich krasse Dinge gesehen, die im Umfeld des MetaLabs gebaut worden sind für das jährlich stattfindende Festival für Cocktail-Robotik. Also wo Roboter gebaut werden, die Cocktails mixen, ausschenken etc. Und da gab es, beeindruckend war zum Beispiel, eine Maschine, die auf Basis von einer Betonmischmaschine Wodka und Orangensaft vermischt hat.
Für die größeren Hackerspaces, okay.
Überall. Ich fand's auch mal krass, wo dann irgendwann in Köln in einer Dingfabrik gesagt wurde, ja wir haben da irgendwie mal so einen Industrieroboter erhalten. Wir müssen unsere Halle auflösen, wollt ihr den haben? Und formen dann irgendwie mit so einem tonnenschweren Industrieroboter an für 6-Achsen-Verfahren und so. Können wir den hier irgendwo abstellen?
Und jetzt möchte ich ganz zum Schluss noch etwas für die wirklich Anfänger fragen. Also jemand, der vielleicht diesen Podcast runtergeladen hat und dann so denkt, Mensch, ich würde da wirklich gerne mal hin und wieder das angucken. Jetzt ist es ja so, dass so ein Hackspace, wenn man da als Fremder an so einem offenen Tag reinkommt, also irgendwie Ehrfrucht gebieten, da sitzen halt Leute und frickeln halt alle an irgendwas und sind auch mit sich beschäftigt. Und es gibt ja sozusagen keinen Türsteher oder irgendwas. Was ist denn der beste Weg als Neuling, um in einem Hackspace sozusagen, um den kennenzulernen? Also als wirklich jemand, der gar keine Ahnung hat, also der nicht aus dem CCC in ein Umfeld kommt, der wirklich denkt, ich finde diese ganzen Themen spannend, aber ich hatte noch nie damit zu tun, ich möchte das jetzt mal machen.
Ja, also der offene Tag ist natürlich schon ganz praktisch dafür. Die meisten Hackspaces haben mittlerweile auch das Bewusstsein dafür, dass dort dann neue Leute aufschlagen könnten und meist dann irgendwie ein, zwei Personen quasi abgesetzt, um neue Leute halt zu empfangen. Was praktisch sind natürlich Spaces, wo eine Bar ist. Da kann man dann einfach mal irgendwie hingehen, sich eine Mate holen und dort dann mit dem Barroboter halt ins Gespräch reinkommen und einfach mal ein bisschen Gespräche führen.
Ich mache ein komisches Bild in meinem Kopf, aber gut. Mit dem Barroboter sprechen. Na gut.
Ich glaube, das Beste ist halt, wenn man selber begeistert ist und ein Projekt hat und das dann halt auch vorstellt. Also alle sind da, weil sie von irgendwas begeistert sind. Das kann Industrieroboter sein, das können Brettspiele sein. Wichtig ist nur, du brennst für eine Sache und möchtest diese Begeisterung mit der Welt teilen. Das ist schon mal ein guter Einstieg in Hackerspace.
Aber aufpassen, das sind Nerds. Wenn du da zu stark und zu schnell mit viel Intuismus reingehst, dann ist das auch nicht immer so fördernd.
Jetzt bin ich verwirrt.
Na ja, wenn du jetzt in so ein Space reinkommst und sagst, hey, guck mal, ich hab ein cooles Projekt mitgebracht, kann ich das mal hier vorstellen? Und jetzt nimmt man meine ganze Aufwechslung auf mich und so weiter. Ich glaube, das klappt auch nicht so immer. Am besten mal langsam ins Gespräch reinkommen, mal eine Maht holen und dann weiter klauen. Immer. Bis der Schlesien Design Patterns drin.
Kloputzen auch. Und Vereinsgründung. Vielen Dank, Pylon, für's Einblick geben. Und Kat, die noch mal sagen wird, wie es jetzt weitergeht mit dem neuen Hackerspace, den es noch gar nicht gibt.
Ja, also wir sind jetzt ja erstmal jeden Donnerstag im X-Hain, in Friedrichshain, in der Grünberger Straße. 14 ist das. Und wer sich irgendwie als Frau identifiziert und da mal vorbeikommen möchte, ist sehr herzlich eingeladen. Wir sind auch sehr freundlich. Und ansonsten kann man sich irgendwie informieren, wie es genau bei uns weitergeht auf unserer Twitter-Seite und auf unserer Homepage, die heißt heartofcode.org. Also kann man finden. Und da gibt es auch einen Blog und es gibt auch ein E-Mail-Newsletter. Der E-Mail-Newsletter wird dann einfach in einem Blog gepostet hinterher. Also wenn man irgendwie zu faul ist, sein E-Mail zu lesen, kann man es auch da immer nachlesen, was passiert, ein bisschen Zeit verzögert, wenn wir Zeit haben, es mal einzuflicken. Also so kann man sich informieren, wie es weitergeht. Wir haben auch einen Kalender. Wir haben extrem viele Events jetzt in nächster Zeit. Wir sind auf der Republika, einige von uns geben da Talks. Wir haben einen Stand, wir haben ein Meetup. Wir sind auf einem Tech-Summit mit einem Stand, ein Meetup und ein Talk.
Kommt nicht an euch vorbei.
Genau, wir haben diverse Workshops, wir verkaufen wie gesagt Schnaps, vielleicht gegen Spende am 1. Mai in Kreuzberg, da kann man uns finden.
Und auch vielen Dank an Gizmo von der Raumfahrtagentur. Sehr schön. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, falls ihr noch einen Hackerspace habt, wo ihr denkt, den müsste man unbedingt erwähnen oder zumindest gesehen haben, schreibt uns gerne in die Kommentare. Mein Name ist Markus Richter, ich bedanke mich nochmal bei allen meinen Gästen und dem Publikum. Und ich kann noch eine Sache sagen, bevor ich gehe, lasst euch nicht überwachen und macht immer schön. Eure Backups. Tschüss!